[Laughter]
hey everybody happy friday night here we
are once again
getting ready hopefully this hopefully
the sound is working it looks like it is
yeah because this microphone turns
itself off inexplicably yeah did i tell
you that the other day i recorded a
whole like half an hour video and i was
all excited about it and then i went to
edit it and it was no sound and then i
went back and opened obs i was like [ __ ]
you
it had turned my microphone off i don't
know why it's a ghost yeah michael who
did it microphone on my [ __ ]
tablet does weird [ __ ] too like
i can send i can send a video and audio
over it
over it most of the times but then
sometimes inexplica inexplicably if like
i'll try to take a video
you can barely hear it it'll be like
real low and real crackly
i wonder if is it is it your finger over
the
condenser right no i don't think it is
it might be
could be because to be honest with you i
don't have any idea where the condenser
mic is on my phone so i could totally be
doing that right like when i'm recording
video with my phone although so far that
hasn't i'm trying not to like yeah try
not to hit this thing because all the
records have falled out so everything in
here is like very precarious yeah like
it's all piled and plugged into various
things and [ __ ] like that every time you
hit something it's like 40 other things
like domino down yeah
okay i'm just i'm not gonna touch it i'm
not gonna touch it like later on it
might go
like that though
i'm serious yeah so today's friday it's
another friday's
open lines just uh you guys can drop it
any kind of comments or questions you
can drop them in the comments section
we'll we'll talk about them but people
are just starting to come in user
accounts going up i think it was
five now there's eight it's everybody's
starting to climb in
um
tammy's here
murder hornets why is that falling uh
it's just because because you turned the
fan on okay
oracle's in
danny goes faces
danny rowland goes face says jurassic
world dominion was a long waste of time
was in my opinion they should have
killed the series after the film before
dominion just saying to be honest with
you um i saw the first jurassic park and
i enjoyed it very much i still think
it's an amazing movie i didn't really
feel compelled to see any of the sequels
though and honestly i couldn't even tell
you how many sequels there were and like
i said i thought the first film was
badass yeah but they're like really good
but i was just kind of like now once
that i'd seen that i was just kind of
like okay i've seen that i can move on
to other things now i can move on with
my life they got to come up with some
kind of [ __ ] excuse i mean
really into that but you know i guess
we'll i don't know because you know i'm
more a horror person you know i like so
yeah i'll watch horror sequels sometimes
but
dinosaur movie i was like yeah that was
badass but it was just like i don't
really need to see another one because i
already saw that i already saw it it's
just cashing in on kids liking dinosaurs
well yeah i mean you know that's the
american version of a godzilla movie
trail that's all it is and i mean i you
know i loved dinosaurs when i was a kid
i had like all these books about them
and i knew all the i was like that nerdy
kid that knew all the names of them and
yeah all of their habits and [ __ ] like
that yeah
when i was little
i would have loved if i was a little kid
when they had when it came out
you know i wasn't i was already grown
pretty much when it went when jurassic
park came well i was too like it was
good i think 93. that was steven
spielberg i think it was it had it it's
a really good movie yeah it had a good
tone and everything but like
one's enough
yeah it was just like that was just that
was perfect the way it was yeah you
can't improve on it you can't you know
it kind of like came out and it's like
yeah it's a badass flick and it's like
that's really all that needed to be said
i really didn't think they needed to
continue on kind of like kind of like
that movie species one was enough
they kept bringing it back
some people say the other one some some
say that the other ones were pretty good
but
i didn't even care i don't i don't i
don't think i ever saw them i just saw
the first one species yeah i mean
generally even with horror franchises
that i really like
um
i usually don't feel all that compelled
to see the sequels you know what i'm
saying like sometimes i will just but
i rarely see anything that and it's not
so much that i didn't like the original
it's like sometimes i loved the original
it's just that i loved the original so
much that i don't want the memory of it
to be besmirched by
some like inferior
like sequel to it you know what i'm
saying and i'm just like y'all like that
that was good that was good the first
thing that you did like you don't have
to like do it again it's fine funny
funny thing about jurassic park is that
the cg and that held up
i was just getting better than some of
the [ __ ] which is crazy because yeah you
see jurassic park from 1993 for [ __ ]
sake yeah and the
the [ __ ] cgi and that looks
incredible it still looks incredible it
looks better than a lot of them yeah and
i've seen some movies like recently
where the cgi looked shittier than that
yeah and that was
how many how many years ago was that was
that like 20 years ago that was like 20
years ago look how shitty the cg was and
[ __ ] i am legend
and that was 2007. yeah
that's and you know what when we were
watching i am legend i thought that
exact thing i was like man stephen
spielberg made jurassic park in 1993 and
it looked like a million times better
than this this was like 2003 there's
like no excuse right after 2007 there's
like no excuse for
for your [ __ ] to look like that
that's my phone yeah i know so what the
[ __ ] man the demons are coming after me
no it's all the telemarketers which
amounts to the same thing
they're all calling me every time i well
one thing that i like that the new i
don't know if all the phones do this now
but i like that the phones when it rings
it doesn't just say unknown number it
says telemarketer or it says spam risk
on it which again telemarketer so i was
like oh well thank you and i can just
kind of go quickly yeah evidently
everybody in this area is getting
constant if you have a phone which our
phones i don't have a phone i just use
jenny's phone i'm like [ __ ] phone i use
that i don't want them calling me
because it but what they would do right
now is they would call me 24 7 about
buying this house evidently
evidently everybody who owns a house
uh
in this area is being [ __ ] called
[ __ ] three or four times a day by
blackrock they're trying to buy up all
the houses for more than what you paid
and the thing too is that once you buy a
house you get on well that's public
knowledge yeah and so a lot of companies
will get those lists especially they're
trying to like sell you [ __ ] so you're
gonna get like all kind of like spam
calls like hey you need some solar
panels hey you need this hey you need
that hey you need plumbing hey you need
this that and the other so yeah that's
you know that's just gonna happen like i
said i don't i don't answer my phone
ever so
i see if that other house like this that
they're let our ex-landlord own see if
that [ __ ] sells i'm gonna keep an eye
on it
yeah man because evidently they're
supposed to be they're trying to buy up
everything that's what i heard i don't
know if it's true
but that black rock is black brock and
vanguard are trying to buy up everything
in any decent area
because they're afraid they're going to
lose all their money if [ __ ] if
hyperinflation kicks in so they want to
own land
you know assets is where it's at if
hyperinflation kicks in
we'll see
dj maniacs i ain't getting out of this
house i don't care if they offer me
they're going to have to offer me twice
what i paid for it before i applied
maybe if they gave me a million dollars
yeah they gave us a million yeah you'd
have to pay me twice
three times or something like that well
that's what i mean actually twice right
that would be almost a million years
yeah
that would be nice
yeah if they came to you and said hey
we'll give you a million dollars and
they're like okay
yeah
i try to make sure i had a place to go
to though before i took that well if you
had well yeah i mean if you had a
million dollars you could pretty much go
where you wanted not to fit hyper
inflates [ __ ] six months from now
you just buy a whole house you pay this
one off and use the half a million to
buy another house well yeah that's free
well then yeah you got to have a place
to go that's what i would do actually if
they're owning up all if they already
own all the available ones then [ __ ]
[ __ ] we could always just go down and
try to see if that dab drug lord mansion
is still for sale
hit that committee
yeah i almost went almost i was i
thought about getting the drug lord
mansion but this this i this that was a
cool looking house yeah it was it was
old though so i'm sure it would have
1950s yeah so i'm sure it would have
needed a lot of work
um but it was so cool looking inside the
thing was that it was all brick and
stone yeah so
you don't need much air conditioning
once it's once it's cooled in there for
yourself oh [ __ ]
no i know exactly what it is i know
exactly how it works
they're they're very fuel efficient once
the house is cold it stays cold like an
ice box
and um because the houses in brazil were
like that and that was a spanish house a
spanish house and they just did it like
that it was cool looked like something
from uh
looked like something from um the
caribbean looked all [ __ ]
like something you see in cuba you know
didn't love that green carpet but yeah
i mean i shagged carpet from the 70s
honestly i didn't mind the color of the
carpet it was just that it was clearly
really old and it was kind of like
rocked up in places and you'd have to
like pull it there's a lot of [ __ ]
work it had been done that's what i'm
saying so
it would have ended up costing more
i mean you're looking at the inside of
the [ __ ] house man look like ricardo
montebron was gonna step around the
corner it did it was kind of it was
pretty rad all stucco [ __ ] it had a
wood
big wood that was salvaged out of a
[ __ ] spanish mission yeah mission
church it was so cool looking wrought
iron [ __ ] chandeliers and stuff and a
lot of um like brown
blown glass like not what not blowing
glass what do you call it stained glass
windows it looked like the inside of a
dab spanish church in a way i mean you
could have got the [ __ ] out of that big
time yeah it did look like the inside of
like an old spanish church yeah and i'm
kind of like i'm into it yeah i was into
it i don't know how you
wire it imagine you know i guess there
were just pipes conduit running through
the walls
i was probably poured concrete a lot of
it because i didn't see any external
wiring because sometimes some houses in
central and south america like that
there's metal conduit running down the
outside of the wall because you can't
drill a hole in it it was and the houses
pre-date electricity so you just have to
do the other conduit on the outside you
know
but uh it was a cool looking little
house looked like some off damn miami
vice it looked like a damn drug lord's
house it probably was probably imagining
like i said i i i thought it was cool
looking but then i thought to myself
well that's gonna cost a lot of money
probably to get up to code had a private
road went to it and it had a uh had a
pier
for a boat and and it was on the back of
a lake had a big lake
it also had like uh it had like a second
floor like a veranda like a porch type
of thing so you could kind of like sit
out yeah on the pick and it was big you
could put your gym equipment out there
work out on the roof or sunbathe or
whatever it looked like somewhat of a
miami vice
episode
yeah it was neat yeah i really really
liked and it looked like it i liked the
thing that i liked the most about it
other than like all the spanish mission
stuff was i really liked that it had
like a bedroom and a bathroom and stuff
like that that i could have used for an
office and it was way at the end of this
like long haul and it was like off by
itself and i really kind of liked that
it was bigger than this house
and a little bit cheaper
yeah
i mean it was about the same but it was
a little bit cheaper it was a little bit
cheaper
and uh but i think the size was probably
50 bigger than this one
i don't remember i think it was
about 50 bigger and it had a
a lot it had
the bottom floor
had a carport you could drive in and it
didn't really close behind it was like a
it had arches that went around the
outside it was kind of like a covered
the first floor was
the first floor was the floor but then
it had like a covered carport had arches
on one side yes it didn't have a garage
but it had like this massive like
covered carpet right it looked like
something you could ride a stage coach
in
it did look like that it's more like
what it was it did look like that yeah
which like i said it was very cool yeah
neat looking and if you had the money
like i said you could goth the [ __ ] out
of that yeah i was just looking at that
thing going man
think of the money yeah you know
because you'd have to replace the
carpeting
and uh it had a real expensive drapery
that had faded out and it was kind of a
teal color but i don't think it was
always teal it looked like it might have
been blue at one time
but it looked like velvet
velvet
um
curtains remember yeah there were my
curtains drapes yeah a bunch of drapes
real gotheed out looking looked like
some old spanish stuff and i loved all
the all the wood trim and the front door
was like this beautiful like hand carved
yeah wood kind of man solid wood about
four inches thick everything gorgeous
and it was there was stuff that was
taken out of a spanish church yeah and
when those when the house was
constructed in the early 50s it was
quite a cool repurposed day yeah late
40s
late 40s i think it was it was i can't
remember when
it was built but yeah
yeah it was super cool looking
um oracle asked jenny have you ever read
the dr greta helsing series of books
about a doctor in the uk that treats
monsters no i haven't but that actually
sounds really good i had never actually
never heard of those i'm gonna have to
like i'm gonna have to write that down
because
yeah
um samantha said where would we move to
i'd stay in this area
yeah i wouldn't go far
yeah i mean like i said we're not
looking to we just moved to this place
like six months ago what was it no it
was more than six months ago
no it's coming up on it's about seven
months seven eight months no we moved
here
in
it was right around my birthday which is
the end of september
okay so
yeah it's been longer than seven months
okay
it's been more like nine months gotta
start doing the paperwork for uh
for uh
december next january coming so i can
get the uh
the the uh disabled veteran [ __ ] tax
[ __ ] breaks on the [ __ ] property
taxes here now yeah 300 bucks a month
yeah that's a lot of money yeah so yeah
you definitely gotta start doing that
because yeah like i said you gotta start
putting the paperwork in you have to be
you can
you have to do it like in the december
before the
before the year you begin to work you
begin to live in the house so yeah i
couldn't do it for last year
well i mean because we moved into the
house like last like late september
early october 2021 but we rented for a
couple of months yeah and then we
decided right that's what it was to buy
it that's why it was and so it was like
too late and january had last so i
couldn't apply yeah so yeah apply for in
a jet if you have to get it all ready by
january 1st
if i remember correctly so they can
start it
end of december january 1st
that's what you got to do
that's what you got to do
anyone ever seen the film pacific rim
and if so is it worth watching it's
worth watching i mean if you like big
robots fighting each other it's pretty
good yeah it looked good i thought it
was dumb
i mean it's dumb but that's kind of like
the appeal of it i guess it's just like
i said just dumb like robots punching
each other sometimes that's all you want
out of life
kind of like
kind of like uh
the the new godzilla type stuff with my
throat and everything
uh that last that last godzilla was
pretty good it was they had kong in it
didn't it
yeah
i can't even remember yeah i'm
completely like that one's pretty good i
like kong skull island out of them all i
thought that was the best one yeah that
one was pretty fun actually
hey david's here hey how you doing how
you doing
are you going to
mannequins this evening no
no
i i was asking dave we're not oh
i thought he was asking you no
but
because i'm kind of i'm kind of broke
kind of broke until the 21st yeah so you
know got a lot of [ __ ] to hit us at once
yeah a lot of bills always kind of like
well have both of these [ __ ] central
air systems in here [ __ ] checked
and uh
inspected they [ __ ] recharged them to
clean the inside and outside coils
and i was kind of
lost track of the [ __ ] i thought it was
going to be about 400 bucks
and then i remembered no i got two
systems yeah it was like 700 to get both
it was 700 yeah well they kept i mean
the ac works it's just sometimes it ices
up like it ices up yeah so it's like you
kind of have to crawl like right out
there there's like a little thing in the
wall you take the thing out and then you
have to crawl into the pipe and like
have a heat gun like melt the ice in
there but summer was common and i never
had these things looked at i wanted the
charges checked and make sure everything
was good and
yeah they're good now they were they
were both one of them was low two pounds
the other one was low one pound
of coolant so uh then that could that
caused me and then i hadn't cleaned the
outside and the inside coils
it's running good now although the dude
told me he says if you move it from 71
which since i had it before since you
move it to 73 you'll save about 30
on your [ __ ] energy bills i was like
really yeah so
so we're trying that out i moved it down
to 73. it feels hot as [ __ ] to me
see i think that's just you though
because honestly and i don't know if
it's just i mean this room like this
office i don't know if it's because i
never opened the [ __ ] windows because
[ __ ] the sun
or i don't know what it is but this
office is always cold it's because and
that's fine because the ac is right
there
i guess so you get good pressure yeah
yeah i mean it blows in here i mean look
i have like i have a jacket like on the
back at all times it is always freezing
cold in here and like i said i'm fine
with that hey what um where's the uh
the smoke detector
it hasn't been there since we moved in i
bought one but i never installed it okay
because i forgot about that i forgot
about it you have it i'll put it in yeah
i have it i can't remember what it is
but yeah like before like when we first
moved in like when remember when i came
uh earlier like before you got here and
i like painted the room and [ __ ] like
that and put all the furniture in it and
then i was like oh i don't have a smoke
detector in this room like there's you
know the hookup is there but the actual
smoke detector been like pulled off so i
bought one and then i was like oh yeah i
gotta install that and then i forgot
yeah all right or i have it somewhere
oracle has to leave
david says he's going to the club
tonight yeah yeah
i wanted to see what they were doing on
saturday night but like i said i don't
really have a [ __ ] ton of money though
that's kind of why i'm like
yeah and plus we gotta go see jean
love's jezebel yeah on the 17th on like
next week yeah next friday oh that'll be
next friday yeah oh [ __ ] so we might not
be able to do the show next friday or we
might have to do it earlier yeah
we could do it earlier we'd have to yeah
we'll have to do the i didn't even
realize that it was a friday yeah i
guess or we can do it on a saturday i
mean we can do the show earlier or yeah
maybe we can do the show on saturday
saturday night that might be that might
be easier yeah because i didn't realize
that the jean loves chess ball show was
on friday
[ __ ] i gotta buy those tickets too
goddammit yeah
danny rowling says finish season four
stranger things uh wasn't bad but kind
of ripped off nightmare on elm street
also homage to a bunch of other 80s
films and 90s films days confused cough
cough okay um i watched the first four
episodes um and i think there's three
left so i haven't finished it yet so
don't spoil anything i do love though
that one of the episodes had that
wonderful kate bush song running up that
hill
and the
and the fact that it was in stranger
things pushed it back into the top ten
because so many people like bought it
and like downloaded it which i thought
was like super funny
and you know what like last week when we
were at mannequins
i was thinking because uh because paul
the dj he played it and i was just kind
of like oh this must be because it was
in stranger things but i didn't realize
until i read an article like later on in
the week that they're like yeah that it
got like it got like such a big thing
like that they actually like went to
kate bush for comment like how do you
feel about your song being in the top 10
again like this many years after it came
out because it came out what 85
something like that
but you know that's kind of that's
pretty cool though because that is an
awesome song what song again running up
that hill i don't know that yeah you do
if you heard it you recognize it
why is it been back on the charts
because it was in uh stranger things oh
okay they used it in a stranger thing
so that's why and i thought that was
cool because when i was watching i can't
remember what episode it must be one of
the first four because that's all the
ones i've seen there's three left that i
haven't watched them yet but i was just
like oh kate bush neat but
i didn't realize like how big of an
impact that would have because they used
like most of the song you know what i
mean
so i thought that was kind of neat uh
speaking of disappointing movies what
does everyone think of the avatar 2
trailer holy [ __ ] did they actually
really make an avatar too
i was underwhelmed for 13 years in the
making i want it to be so awesome i'm
lucky to have survived witnessing it
um i didn't love the first movie yeah i
didn't like to be honest with you i mean
it was fine but
i thought it was derivative very [ __ ]
samey kind of i don't know it's just
it's weird because it's interesting how
it's one of those weird ass movies that
was like [ __ ] massive like at the
time it came out it made all the money
and it was just like there was me there
was kind of like memes about it i don't
even know if it was like maybe it was
before like maybe they were making porn
over it that's what i mean it was like
this huge thing like there was halloween
costumes and [ __ ] like that and then
like a couple years later everybody's
like avatar who like everybody like
forgot about it was like that's crazy
then it was like massive and then like a
few years later nobody literally really
remembers i saw it in the theater and i
was just kind of indifferent i was just
like yeah okay blue people all right
yeah [ __ ] your tree you know i just
didn't yeah i just didn't i didn't
really i mean it was good it's just it
wasn't anything
i didn't really care i was just
indifferent yeah that's what i mean like
i was like oh that was fine yeah but it
didn't really i don't know why they
liked it so much
it was just i thought there was
something about it that just like hit
and that's really i don't know that's
like really interesting to me i'm so
like i said i'm not a big like
blockbuster movie person
like i will see them sometimes but a lot
of times that's why like a lot of times
i kind of see them i'm like oh that was
neat but then like
a year like a year later i'm like wait
did i see that i thought elita battle
angel was a lot better
and that and a battle angel flopped
basically
you know i thought it was a lot better
yeah i mean
and that's another one of the cg movies
basically the whole movie cg
that's why i compared the two
kind of sci-fi you know yeah i just i
thought elita was a lot better but yeah
it was i mean i've to be fair i've only
seen avatar once yeah um i didn't see it
at the theater like somebody loaned it
to me and i watched it and i was like oh
that was fine
but like i said i'm not really the the
intended audience for that i don't like
big blockbuster movies generally
i i mean they're okay but i don't really
a lot of times i can't really like get
into them it just seems like it's a lot
of spectacle and like yeah there's
something about a lot of spectacle and
then i'm realizing i'm like yeah you
know what the humans are the bad guys in
this one and then you know
i'm kind of enjoying it and i'm like
well why am i watching this then that
was that was kind of the way i felt
about it you know
if we're the bad guys and why am i
watching this
you didn't get that vibe
well not real well the thing about it is
that i kind of feel like any movie that
has villains in it like the villains are
human so it's like i didn't really see
why that would be particularly no it's
just another way of looking at you know
what i mean like when you're seeing
aliens you're rooting for the humans
yeah because they're fighting the
xenomorphs right
and now the movie tries to put you in
the pres into the into the position of
rooting for the aliens
and to see the aliens kill the humans
and i'm just going to like why am i
watching this [ __ ] that's how that's how
i interpreted it you know i i wasn't
bothered yeah i just i mean i'm
sensitive to things like that i'm like i
was like you know well why am i watching
this very sensitive
okay
then you know i don't really care i
don't get them i don't get offended by
stuff like that i don't get offended by
yourself yeah i'm just kind of like
whatever movie i'm watching i'm like i
don't care what whatever your message is
or whatever your thing is it's just just
entertain me
um and then we'll see
you know where we go from there i'm not
like you know i'm not offended by
anything
so
that so the movie to me like i said you
know i got it but i was just kind of
like you know that was fine it's just i
didn't really get a lot of emotional
attachment to it no it was boring but
like i said it's that's just because i'm
not a big blockbuster movie person
because i and i'm not like [ __ ] on
people that like that kind of stuff
because you know sometimes you just want
to like turn your brain off and watch
like a big spectacle movie and that's
fine like sometimes i want to do that
too but that's usually why i stick with
more like indie kind of [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying it's just i just thought
it was boring it was kind of boring kind
of boring like i don't really remember
that much about it like i remember it
looking pretty but that was about it you
know what i mean go on [ __ ] like two
or three hits of acid and watch it
probably is awesome you're not a man
[ __ ] you know just
everything's blue
dj maniac says i never root for the
humans we suck yeah pretty much
john gore said district nine was like
that too that's right and uh and
district nine was a million times better
than avatar yeah yeah i mean district
nine was a fantastic movie i don't
actually think we've
reviewed that have we i've seen it i've
seen it uh several times but yeah i love
that movie actually district 9 was
entertaining
it was yeah it was but like i said see
that's more of like an indie movie right
that's not like a big budget type of not
necessarily you know what i mean
i didn't like the fact that district 9
they never really followed up on the
story i guess the dude i guess he said
what he had to say and that that was it
but uh that guy turned into the alien
with the dna
and the ship got away i guess that's i
guess that was the end of it and that
was the end of the story yeah but see i
would rather that than like see like 50
sequels to it yeah where it just gets
where you just get like diminishing
returns probably i think it's better
generally to kind of like leave your
audience wanting more like oh i wish
they'd make a sequel yeah rather than
them actually making a sequel and being
like that kind of sucked you know yeah
honestly i think that's probably better
what i did like what i did like about
district 9 though is that the aliens
really were different
you know they were basically like
lobster looking things yeah like
human-sized lobsters
which that would be terrifying if it was
human-sized lobsters and they'd be like
we're getting you back for red lobster
[ __ ] like keeping us in the tank
and then boiling
[ __ ] and the contrary to like what you
would think they weren't that
intelligent only some of them were most
of them were just kind of dumb
so like humans yeah
well no they didn't remember they didn't
really have much
much of even kind of like um
uh
they were just kind of real docile and
[ __ ] un uninterested in things they
just they just did functions on that
ship
and once they were off that ship most of
them just kind of were real aimless
but there was evidently some kind of
caste system because that one
had kind of like a human
uh human style intelligence well it's
more
it's just that the other ones are kind
of almost like robots
in a way well it was kind of like uh the
movie was made in south africa so it was
kind of they were talking about
apartheid is what they were talking
about so that's what it was
david parker said avatar was pushed hard
as the first real 3d movie yeah exactly
and like i said it was neat for that i
didn't see it in 3d like i said i just
saw it on dvd at home but
even then i was like ooh that looks nice
but i didn't really i didn't really feel
any emotional connection to it you know
what i mean not in the same way that i
do with like smaller kind of movies the
more like stuff is more spectacle
the less
engaged i get with it you know because i
feel like they're just like
jangling keys in front of my face or
something
um let's oh somebody was talking about
uh friday the 13th even in the 80s
rumors were going around they were going
to make 13 movies yeah i remember that
they didn't make it though uh they
there's there's only 12.
i you know what the way it's going
nowadays like with all the new halloween
movies and like all these new screen
movies and [ __ ] like that i would it
would not shock me if they had like
friday the 13th part 13. um you know
we'll see how that goes
uh hugo says i just watched jason x's
hilarious i liked it yeah and john smith
said i have a soft spot for jason x
jason x
is that's the one where he goes to space
right
i don't remember i think that's right i
only like like the first four or five of
them but well i liked jason x just for
how audacious
audaciously stupid it was it was just
kind of like we were taking this concept
and like pushing it to its ultimate
[ __ ] like [ __ ] i was just kind of
like i respect that i respect that you
did that it is very funny that movie and
i'm sure it was it was actually meant to
be funny it wasn't meant to be like
taken seriously
so i don't think any of the movies were
meant to be taken seriously to be honest
with you
uh let's see uh yeah murder hornet said
i think i made it to part five
yeah it's like
i mean i kind of feel like the first
one's fine the second one's the best one
sorry
um
the fifth one's good too
and
other than that
i used to like the third one until i
rewatched it i liked it less i have it
yeah we have all of them i think we have
all of them you know how the first got
the first four or five oh okay i thought
we had that box set that had all of them
in it no
no i've been watching if i did
probably yeah now i think we got the
first i got the best ones
which i think four or four of them five
of them maybe i don't get five i don't
think i have five yeah because the fifth
one is actually really good yeah the
fifth one is actually really good i
think the number two and number five i
think are my favorite ones yeah i mean
the first one's good too but it's
honestly when we were re-watching them
the first one is a little bit
boring
yeah um one time three
it's not as
the hilarious thing is that i kind of
feel like even though now there's like
friday there's like the first one it's
like unrated but when you watch it it's
really not
there's not gory it's not gory it's not
and it's funny because it had such a
reputation i mean it came out in 1980 or
whatever it was so it was maybe gory it
actually wasn't even that gory for the
time it would seem like way no it was
gory or [ __ ] that
came out it made you think it was though
yeah it was kind of sneaky that way yeah
it made you think that
it would convince you you saw something
but you didn't actually see it it was it
was real tricky with the camera angles
and the editing
well i think texas chainsaw massacre did
that yeah like really well too it's like
because i remember people talking about
texas chainsaw massacre after oh my god
did you do that thing where he like um
cut open the dude in the wheelchair uh
you know and like with the chainsaw that
didn't happen it was implied
like you kind of saw it from the back
but you didn't see that actually he
didn't see his gut squirting out or
nothing like that it was just implied
but it was like sneaky the way it made
you like remember it like as way warrior
than it was and i think friday the 13th
had the same kind of vibe because when i
rewatched it i was like amazed at how
because i hadn't seen it a long time and
i was like amazed at how tame it was
it's very tame
you could probably show that to a kid
to be for the first friday the 13th i
saw it as a kid well i did too but i'm
just saying like even nowadays like you
probably show that to a kid and they'd
be like man they'd probably be like
bored they'd probably like fall asleep
well what gets you is the music
the music the timing of the edit
and the screaming
uh it'll fool you into thinking that you
saw something you did yeah there is a
couple times where people get their
throats cut
um
asparagus put through a couple but you
but they edit it in a funny way you just
see the spirit coming down like through
other side of the bed on the other side
of the bed and that scene is totally a
rip-off from a mario yeah by the way you
didn't actually see it go through the
person now
and i think even when somebody's one
girl gets axed to the face yeah well no
they show their axe coming down and then
next time it's already in it it's
interfacing yeah the edit is real fast
and real tricky and it's it's obviously
just a fake [ __ ] they just took a
[ __ ] axe and cut the the end of it to
fit somebody's head but yeah and they
put some blood right there that's
that's all they did and then uh they
i think there's a i think there's a
part where somebody's throat gets cut
but i don't know if you actually see the
knife
in the throat
i don't i think it was i have to go back
and look at it
now was that the first like the
hitchhiker girl like the first one was
towards the end because i know i'm
pretty i'm pretty sure she got her
throat cut because i remember well
because like i think tom savini worked
on that and so i remember seeing like a
documentary about him where he was
working on like how like showing how he
did that yeah we saw we saw the first
one recently i was i was kind of
surprised because i hadn't seen it since
i was a kid really of kind of how tame
it is it is very tame but i didn't
remember it that way as a kid
and watching it you could see how
creative they were with the editing yeah
to make you think you saw something but
you didn't they just which is pretty
ingenious yeah for just like a slasher
movie that's that cheap which was
essentially a halloween ripoff and they
made it to be a halloween ripoff they're
not ashamed of that fact they're just
basically like hey halloween was awesome
let's make something like that but make
it like gorier
you know what i mean
uh murder hornet says poltergeist scared
the [ __ ] out of me as a kid yeah uh yeah
me too i mean that came out when i was
10 and i think that i saw it in the
theater like i think my parents might
have taken me to see that because i
would be like scary movie i don't see it
you know why
if i remember correctly
i saw the
i saw the trailer for it
i i think i saw a trailer for it after
um i went to mammoth what year did that
come out
1982.
okay so it was before
no no no it was after
i don't remember if it was summer or
winter though okay but it was definitely
in 1982.283
i think poultry guys had i think i think
my i think i think mammoth happened in
83.
you told me you told me christmas 82.82
okay
so i don't remember what i saw first i
remember seeing that
um
that uh
trailer
in the theater
and i was like i'm not gonna see that
but i don't
know yeah but i don't remember i don't
remember i don't remember if it was
before or after [ __ ] mammoth happened
i remember i think it was after
after my mammoth happened and i saw that
trailer and i was like ah
i'm not going to see that i saw it later
on that is a surprisingly scary movie
for just being like and honestly when i
saw it like yeah the clown [ __ ] is scary
uh the kid eating tree is scary the
[ __ ]
pool with all the corpses in it is scary
the thing that scared me the most when i
was a little kid
was the guy like one of the
parapsychologists or whatever going in
the bathroom and tearing his own face
off yeah i remember that too and then
like all like the steak like scooching
across the counter and like all the meat
coming out like and then being like uh
he was like eating a chicken leg and he
dropped in those maggots all over it
yeah oh that scared the crap out of me
yeah i think that was like the scariest
thing in it to me like the corpses and
[ __ ] that was scary too but i was like i
was horrified by that whole face tearing
off thing i think when i was a little
kid because like i said it came out when
i was 10 and i think like the couple
times that i saw it like after that when
i was maybe like 11 or something the
face tearing off thing was the only one
that i had to go guys i like that
you know what i mean i'm glad that we
wrote mammoth mountain with uh before um
red died
yeah and uh that we got all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] written down because i never
would have remembered the dates if it
wasn't for lois and them because i was i
was young you know
i mean i don't know if you're
remembering it wrong but you told me
when we were writing a book you that you
were pretty sure that it was christmas
1982. yeah i know it's christmas time
yeah you said she said
that's what you told me yeah yeah it was
christmas time i mean you got that from
lois though the exact date i knew it was
christmas it was christmas vacation yeah
because she was an adult at the time and
you were just yeah i wasn't she probably
remembered it wasn't sure if it was 81
82 or 83 yeah we went blurry for a
second all right
because when you're a kid all all years
are kind of the same
at that time yeah they're like yeah yeah
it's another one another christmas i
couldn't really remember exactly what
year it was even to this day so it was
82
that's what yeah christmas a2 so it was
almost 83 yeah
john gore said i watched the last house
on the left remake the other night i
didn't hate it but it's weak compared to
the original i don't think i've watched
the remake of that um the original last
house on the left is seriously one of
the most horrifying movies and i think
the fact that it's low budget makes it
scarier because it is like so so scuzzy
it just seems like something you
absolutely should not be watching
uh and david hess
is just i'm sure he's a lovely man in
real life but holy [ __ ] is he a [ __ ]
dirtbag in that [ __ ] movie and he
always played roles like that i mean i
guess i don't know he just looks like a
dirtbag slasher friends talking about uh
if you guys ever watched the twilight
zone episode little girl lost that was
the inspiration for poultry guys when i
was a kid that [ __ ] episode
fascinated me little girl accidentally
fell through the damn wall
into an into a parallel dimension i love
that i sent the dog in there yeah
when uh i had that poultry guys thing
happened to [ __ ] mammoth mountain i
actually kind of remembered that [ __ ]
um
that episode and kind of drew some
parallels because that particular
episode was really like an episode about
parapsychology more than anything else
yeah they were doing a scientific thing
and trying to figure out
where it began and where it ended and
where was the hole in the wall and all
that you know kind of reminded the way
red was trying to figure out
how somebody could go get in and out of
that [ __ ] room through a closed door
you know man yeah but that's uh oh [ __ ]
let me go check that hold on
i'm waiting on a delivery yeah he's
gotta wait for that all right i got some
horror movie related questions that i
gotta answer
camp guy says texas chainsaw original
gave me a neurotic psychosis for about a
month
yeah that's uh it's intense it's intense
it's like it almost like tips over into
like being funny but like also like
horrific funny you know what i mean uh
murder hornet said fact there was no
blood in the original texas chainsaw i
really don't think there was i mean
it was a lot of it was by implication
like i said you know it was implied that
leatherface got what the [ __ ] was that
dude's name that was in the
god damn it i remember sally i remember
was what guy what was the kid's name in
the [ __ ] wheelchair i totally blanked
but yeah so
but you just see him from the back and
then you see him kind of like going like
he's being like that but you don't like
see his guts falling out and you know
the one girl that gets hung on the meat
hook you don't see her back like going
into the meat hook it's just all like
implication
but to me the creepiest scene in texas
chainsaw was when the one guy goes in
the house and he's like hey looking for
it and then like leather face just like
pops out and like hits him in the head
with a hammer and then like he falls
down and he's like twitching ooh that
[ __ ] freaked me out uh the first time
i saw that
stardust 78 says kane from poltergeist 2
still haunts me in my dreams he was
[ __ ] great poltergeist 2 is actually
really really decent like you know since
we're talking about sequels and stuff
three
not so much um but
that one was a little cheesy and
honestly i
i watched it not too long ago
poltergeist three i mean
and it's still it's an okay movie but
knowing that heather o'rourke like died
like not too soon and she looks very she
looks a little bit sick and she looks
kind of bloated and she looks kind of
sick and you know that some of the shots
are not her because she died before it
was done uh filming um you know i didn't
hate the idea of them like transposing
it to a different place and like the
mirrors and that was neat and everything
like that but
i don't know it just seemed like dumb
but poltergeist 2 is actually like quite
good and like i said kane i think like
[ __ ] makes it
yeah i i'm glad you brought up that uh
that twilight zone episode little girl
lost because that was
we just rewatched this was probably like
i want to say it was like a couple years
ago a couple years ago because i think
netflix has or they used to they had the
entire twilight zone the original
twilight zone series and i think we
watched all of them like over a week or
something like that
and i had forgotten how good like some
of those episodes were and that was
easily like one of my favorite ones i
mean that's just like so that's like
some that's like some modern [ __ ] like
she gets like sucked into some other
dimension she's just like right on the
other side of the wall that's like
freaky as [ __ ]
uh yeah holy parish of doom says uh
texas chainsaw and last house makes a
good double bill movie night oh yeah oh
yeah
both of them like i said very very
scuzzy it's just kind of like
there's something about those early 70s
exploitation films that always
i don't know it just makes them like
creepier because it seems they're they
just seem so like dirty and you kind of
feel like you shouldn't be watching them
like it's some snuff film that you like
came across and [ __ ] like that and it's
just like i know that the directors like
cultivated that vibe but
it definitely like contributes to how
[ __ ]
yucky they are like how and that's why i
think they have a lot because if you
take something like last house on the
left and i didn't see the remake but i'm
assuming because just going by
the remakes of all of those kind of 70s
movies that they did like in the early
to mid 2000s i kind of feel like if they
remade it they probably made it all
slick and everybody's like kind of like
oh these good-looking 20-somethings blah
blah blah and it just doesn't have that
same like illicit
kind of quality to it and if you lose
that you lose a lot of the horror i feel
like
and that was kind of like the shitty
thing that's why i didn't like a lot of
the remakes some of the remakes from the
early 2000s were were good like i liked
the dawn of the dead remake the texas
chainsaw massacre remake was actually
like much better than i was expecting
it's not great but it was much better
than i was expecting
but
they just they slickify everything you
know what i mean they just make
everything feel like it's not scuzzy and
dirty and
it just seems too
i don't know it just seems
i don't know there's something about it
that i don't like it's just it's not
i'm trying to think there's a word and i
had it and then it like slipped away
but it just seems too manicured it just
seems too manicured i guess is what i
don't like about it
uh lynnwood sly says friday 13th was
kevin bacon a pennsylvania native that's
right that's right yeah he was the one
that got killed in the uh it's
interesting how many
uh
very very famous actors get their start
in horror movies well i guess it's
because a lot of directors and [ __ ] like
that you get your certain horror movies
because
horror movies are kind of like
they're the ease i don't know if they're
the easiest but they're one of the
easiest genres to make on a low budget
because the thing about it is that
horror fans will watch pretty much
anything we don't give a [ __ ] it will
like how low just be scary or you know
do something and then we don't care you
don't have to have big stars in it you
don't have to have like big special
effects you don't have nothing like that
as long as you know what you're doing
and it's like super effective i've seen
like amazing amazing horror films like
shot entirely in one room or like one
house or something like that if you know
what you're doing you can really really
do a lot with that genre so i know that
that's why a lot of
directors get their start there so i'm
assuming that's why a lot of their
actors because johnny depp like was
[ __ ] in uh you know nightmare on elm
street
before anybody really knew although i
think he'd been on tv right wasn't he on
21 jump street before that i can't
remember i didn't watch that show but i
remember like him being in that as well
um let's see doo doo doo
start on 78 said i think parts of the
yellow jackets pilot was shot at mammoth
mountain oh [ __ ]
everybody's been telling me to watch
that and i haven't watched it yet but
now that we know that maybe we will
actually
uh get into that
yeah hugo says netflix has all the
twilight zone episodes except season
four
yeah okay yeah i thought they had like a
bunch of them because i know we watched
like all of them
like in a row like one night because
they're very comforting you know
i like putting them on it's kind of like
it's kind of like unsolved mysteries
because a lot of times i'll go to 2b
because they have like all the unsolved
mysteries they have like all 12 seasons
with robert stack and then they have all
the seasons that had dennis farina on it
and it's like so a lot of times if we
just want to like chill out we don't
have to watch anything in particular for
the show then we'll just like put those
on and like find a chill out to it okay
it's in
okay do you want me to make another
drink sure okay
uh john gore says last house on dead end
street is quite memorable too yeah i've
been meaning to watch that one there's
like so many like in franklin thank you
that was that [ __ ] dude's name from
texas chainsaw master i knew it was i i
thought
i was gonna say francis and i was like
no that's not right
but i got like the first few letters
right
give me give me that much i'm not drunk
yet i swear
uh yeah holy perish of doom says the
lo-fi aspect of the 70s flicks is
something that can't be duplicated in
aesthetic terms yeah exactly you can and
i appreciate when filmmakers try to
replicate the aesthetic like i do like
that like for example
take a movie like a recent movie like
antrum which i think just came out in
what 2018 i want to say somewhere around
there
and it was it was pretty effective in
trying to replicate i mean you knew it
was a replication but it was still like
pretty good at doing that
so it can be done but you know it's not
gonna be exactly the same it's not gonna
be exactly the same
okay
i'm gonna refreshing mine up too okay
since i'm up already you might as well
murder hornet says i spit on your grave
is a good cult classic honestly
um i actually really like that movie um
i haven't seen the remakes or actually i
think they did a remake and a sequel but
i haven't seen either one of those but
the original is actually
really really good i mean
it has one of the because i have a thing
about
it's hard for me to like watch um rape
scenes in movies like i will but
i don't know it it they bother me
and the rape scene in ice but on your
grave is
one of the worst things that i've ever
sat through like one of the worst things
because it's so prolonged
and it's so
um
sorted and it's just so it's not like
glamorized at all it's not like
romanticized because i know like some
movies have a tendency to be like oh
it's a rape scene but it's like shot all
sexy and [ __ ] it's like this is not like
that this is like completely
gross and like degrading and it's long
and it just like goes on and on i was
just like oh my god this is like the
most horrible thing i've ever [ __ ]
seen but it's just like so so bad but
you know that's good because like then
you're rooting for her is like yeah kill
these [ __ ] dudes you know what i mean
so it's like that much more satisfying
like at the end when she cuts that
dude's dick off like in the bathtub i'm
like yeah you know what i mean so that's
kind of like
what is that other there was another
movie
there was a more recent movie that i saw
was another like rape revenge because
that's like a whole sub genre
um i think it was just called revenge
wasn't it i think i saw it on netflix
but it might have been shutter i can't
really remember but i think it came out
in
i want to say 2016
somewhere around there but that was also
really really good but that was also
like a rape revenge maybe similar to i
spit on your grave but you know more
recent obviously
and uh but yeah i liked that a lot too
that is actually due for a re-watch
because i watched that a couple years
ago and i thought it was like pretty
[ __ ] great
uh yeah miz45 that's another one that i
uh that i actually really love actually
i wrote a long time ago i wrote like a
little i wouldn't call it like it's like
a mini essay about those two movies like
about
i was kind of talking about like the
rape event genre
you know in general but i was talking
about those two movies because i kind of
feel like those are the two biggest
examples of like rape revenge but you
know
uh have you considered says mr 88 an
episode on colton harris moore aka the
barefoot bandit
teenager hacks dozens of systems steals
and flies an airplane with no training
dodges the fbi across the country
i hadn't but one of the um topics that i
had in the poll
this week was about people who were like
famous imposters like frank abignale and
people like that
which i guess that would kind of like
fit in so if that wins maybe i'll like
throw that in there as well
um
[Music]
gator bait
we did a review of that not too long ago
yeah i think gator bait is like rape
revenge too it is yeah we did um
yeah because gator bait got added to
shutter a couple months back so i think
we did uh a matinee on that like not too
long ago
a japanese movie frozen not to be
confused with the other frozen
is a great rape refrench refrigeration
movie
i would see that one actually
how many [ __ ] movies are gonna be
called frozen because i reviewed a movie
called frozen
that was about
that had it had it was like an early
emily blunt movie
and she was like
giving this guy a ride
like to you know she was going home for
the holidays or whatever and she gave
this guy like it was like a ride-sharing
deal and then they got like stuck out in
the [ __ ] wilderness and the snow that
was called frozen too i checked uh those
uh cakes down there man they look good
he made like pumpkin bread i made
pumpkin bread but i had so much so much
pumpkin puree
because i was growing sugar pumpkins in
the backyard and i had
six the sugar pumpkins are about that
big
they got pretty big i sliced them
i never dealt with sugar pumpkin sliced
them bro uh um roasted them
got the meat out of it and pureed it
i had a lot of it i had to use up i want
to make pumpkin bread
so i made two big old
pans of it in glass pans
and then i made cream cheese frosting
for it
it's nice it's about that tall
you see a reason why i did that is
because uh it says when i was reading up
about that you can freeze it
see yeah so maybe i'll freeze one of
them i don't know we're gonna see how
fast it goes yeah you can freeze cake
yeah but pumpkin bread freeze i don't
know if i can freeze it frosted though
oh maybe not right i don't i don't i
wouldn't advise it because i think
probably the frosting would get all
[ __ ]
freezing i made it but the cake could
probably i made a treat cream cheese
frosting is real good it was three
sticks of butter and a little bit and a
and a chunk of cream cheese that was
about the same size a little bit bigger
the chunk of
cream cheese is probably like the size
of like four sticks of butter i do it by
eye
blended it together
and put about a cup and a half
a cup and a half of sifted
confectioner's chee uh sugar in it and
and a teaspoon of
actually it's a tablespoon of vanilla
man that stuff is so good just whipped
it together man it's really good the
frosting so i'm gonna i can't frost it
until it gets cold yeah it's gotta be a
cold cake it's still warm when you eat
the bottom i'm gonna have to like allow
myself to eat some of that later on but
that's okay because all i've eaten today
is one piece of naan and a little bit of
baba ganoush yeah and two cups of coffee
yeah i got jenny on calorie restriction
well i have neon calories restriction
it's my instincts to feed the [ __ ] out
of a [ __ ] well yeah see that's
why we keep getting into trouble cause i
keep telling him because what he'll do
and i appreciate this i do but it's like
what you do sometimes i'll be up here
working just like mine on my own beeswax
or whatever and then like he'll come up
with this big bowl of food and like i
didn't even know he was making anything
and i'm just like well [ __ ]
[Laughter]
my blood [ __ ] is my blood [ __ ] work
my blood serum concentrate of this well
and you can yeah you can get away yeah
and you will get away with eating a lot
more yeah i eat a lot
i can eat a lot and still lose weight
yeah see i can't do that and the thing
about it too is that and i've mentioned
this before it's just like you know as
much as i would like to eat more
um i usually don't like to because it'll
make me feel cr even though it'll taste
good at the time like an hour later i'll
be like oh like i'll feel really really
bad like i'll feel really ill yeah so
it's better if i because i got to eat
but it's like it's better if i just eat
like little bits yeah i've been feeding
her just a little bit you know and
that's yeah that usually works and
honestly like i said that's the only way
that i can lose weight is like severe
calorie restriction
john smith says the nightingale is an
australian movie on that topic and it's
general genuinely upsetting i've been
wanting to see that because that was
directed by jennifer kent right and she
was the same one that did the babadook
and actually i just rewatched the
babadook today because i'm gonna do a
flickers of fear on it because i bought
it like not too long ago and that movie
really holds up like i remember really
liking it at the time but i hadn't seen
it for several years
and then i was at fye and i was just
like they had it for five bucks and i
was like oh why not i've been wanting to
rewatch this and i watched it again this
afternoon and i'm like man that's still
like really [ __ ] excellent but it's
funny the way
particularly the babadook and like i
guess a lot of this sort of like
elevated horror if you want to call it
that that came out in you know like the
mid
2010s like 2014 2015 whatever it was
i kind of feel like it's super super
divisive like because some people are
just like oh i love the babadook and
somebody were like oh i hate it it
wasn't scary or anything like that so i
don't know i loved it i thought it was
like amazing but you know everybody's
like [ __ ] thing uh slasher friend
said the movie sudden impact is a rape
revenge movie is ripped by a gang and
her sister comes to take revenge yeah
there's a it's a whole [ __ ] sub genre
there's a lot of them there's a lot of
them like i said i kind of feel like i
spit on your grave and miss 45 are kind
of maybe the i don't know if they're the
best known ones but they're kind of like
the most iconic i feel like what's up
sly i see you you're the man bro you're
the man
oh yeah oh my god john goris brings up
uh death in the maiden that's a polanski
film man i haven't seen i saw that once
like a long time ago
uh that's a rape revenge and it has
sigourney weaver and ben kingsley in it
that's right that's right
i haven't seen it in
a long time but i remember it being
really good that's another one that i
that i probably need to rewatch
uh holy parish of doom says the child
actor is a bit over the top in the
babadook he is and i get that but the
whole i mean i kind of felt like i don't
you know i kind of want to save this
like for my review but i did kind of
feel like
one that's kind of what a hyperactive
kid acts acts like and two
you're supposed to think that kid is
annoying his [ __ ] because his mother
thinks he's annoying and [ __ ] and so
you're supposed to like sympathize with
her but she was like oh my god i'm going
to strangle this little [ __ ] you know
what i mean and then it kind of like cuz
because the whole theme of the movie and
stuff like that yeah but please remember
to hit the uh the thumbs up the like
button people
i would i'd appreciate it to help us out
in the algorithms hugo says a lot of
good horror directors worked on night
gallery they did and honestly
i [ __ ] love night gallery yeah they
only made two seasons of that i think
right i think it was only yeah they were
all good too
yeah i'm pretty sure like every single
episode was good i rewatched it
i rewatched the whole series probably
gosh
seven years ago eight years ago you can
buy it on dvd i know i think it's time
like for another re-watch i think
well when i rewatched it i think hulu
had it yeah but i don't know if they saw
that was a long time ago but every every
now and then i like to rewatch the whole
series i just love night gallery there's
just something about it that really
sometimes you can get that stuff on um
on sale like a whole
dvd set
and it's worth buying man because you
have that [ __ ] [ __ ] on
on hard copy and no one can can take it
from you and you can watch it even if
you lose an internet connection
like i did that with the
the logan's run television series
i got it on dvd
and i'm glad i bought it because you
can't get it anymore when it comes up
for [ __ ] sale used a lot of times
dudes want like 80 bucks for it
well it's kind of hard to get
you know because it's like you never
stream it
well it's kind of like forgotten yeah we
kind of talked about that when we talked
about the show because i was kind of
like [ __ ] i'm real into like horror and
70s [ __ ] and stuff like that i didn't
even know that existed yeah and i loved
the movie but i was like oh they made a
series out of that yeah and it was good
writing
yeah the writing was good a lot of the
same writers from uh
original star trek and i think some of
those guys were ended up on next
generation right in [ __ ] episodes
so it's a good move it's it's a good
series
dj maniac says i prefer night gallery to
twilight zone i probably do too well in
the aggregate i probably do but they're
both good they're both good i like them
both honestly i really like a lot of
this i used to i loved like alfred
hitchcock presents i love all those kind
of like horror anthology shows
um i still want to watch i think to be
has
it i don't know if they still have it
but they did like a couple weeks back
when i was looking they had that show
thriller which i think boris karloff
hosted like toward the end of his life
and i remember stephen king bringing
that up in dance macabre and i was like
oh yeah i need to like watch that but i
haven't gotten around to like watching
it yet but i'm pretty sure like 2b has
it
um
mr 88 said i got the entire dexter
series on dvd brand new for 32 dollars
oh yeah not bad yeah i buy that
okay so has anybody seen the new dexter
season because there's a new one right
heavy yeah we haven't watched it i mean
don't spoil it because we haven't
watched it yet but
i just hadn't heard anybody like really
talk like that was good a couple of
people talking about it but i know that
like the end of
you know the end of the last season like
pissed everyone off it didn't oh did you
did you buy the third season of true
detective
no not yet okay we gotta get it yeah oh
that's another thing that i um
they wouldn't yeah somebody's paid for
that no no no it was uh the last duel so
the last day for that yeah no i haven't
bought it yet i wrote it down but i
haven't bought it yet all right
somebody's sending us i think i think
third season a true detective i think
not sure yeah i think dj maniac said
thriller is still up there
uh yes okay so i'm gonna have to get
around to watching that i'm currently
watching an anthology series called
night visions which featured henry
rollins as the host i kind of remember
that i kind of remember that sounds
familiar yeah um i might not have seen
all of them but i'm pretty sure i saw
some of them yeah some good writers had
their stuff adapted for that series yeah
yeah yeah
henry rollins suffered from a lot of the
same [ __ ] glenn dancing just in a
different direction just in a different
direction [ __ ] would just talk
himself into a [ __ ] corner
sometimes i remember one time [ __ ]
they were
they were [ __ ] trolling the [ __ ] out
of out of
out of henry rollins henry ross was
chiding people that uh dudes didn't know
how to make women [ __ ] calm
yeah or something like that
and uh then they started [ __ ] with
him you remember that one
no okay yeah that was back in the 90s
he's a maniac primary he's not wrong
he was [ __ ] saying he was saying that
only he could do it or something i don't
remember i don't remember exactly what
it was okay well that's crazy yeah maybe
he's not wrong in
general maniac remembers [ __ ] he
probably remembers it better than i do i
don't remember exactly what it was i
just remember when that [ __ ] went down
people were [ __ ]
[ __ ] with him for a long time that
was almost kind of like
that particular video was almost kind of
like the dancing gets knocked out video
well it can't have been that well
because i've seen the danza getting gets
knocked out like lots of times but i
haven't seen the henry rollins once so
i'm assuming it hadn't gone to the same
virality yeah it was almost like that
though
it wasn't it was there it was
pre-internet
so rollins didn't get it quite as bad
joe nash says i bought the entire series
of night gallery for twenty dollars oh
yeah it's a good deal holy [ __ ] that's
what i was talking about i might have to
do that sometimes it's better just to
buy the [ __ ] love night gallery yeah
sometimes you can find deals on them
used somebody's selling it [ __ ] used
like 10 bucks delivered i don't know if
they can do that anymore because
delivery is [ __ ] expensive now
because of the gas but
i remember you could get [ __ ] [ __ ]
free delivery every now and then off uh
off of uh youtube you had people that
were i guess they were probably
merchants when it uh who had massive
quantities of dvds
and you could buy something for like two
dollars delete off youtube
not youtube whatever amazon no ebay ebay
ebay
there was some there were some dvds i
got for like two dollars delivered used
off of ebay
and then when it showed up it was
[ __ ] sealed
well you can reseal things because like
i said when i bought like every time if
we go to if when we go to the movies
yeah we always go to like fye because
fye will always have these big um like
bins of dvds and blu-rays that they're
selling off for like five bucks or like
you know two or five bucks or whatever
and they usually have a bin of all
horror movies so i always check because
sometimes they have some really good
ones that i want to like add to my
collection like i said because i bought
the babadook because i wanted that to
re-watch it and it's used but they've
they have a reseal yeah they have a
machine okay well they used to have it
at the print shop i used to work at you
could just yeah it's just like a yeah
you have like a sleeve and then like you
heat it like this [ __ ] i got man i had
the outer [ __ ] paper cover and
everything you know and it looked brand
new
not a scratch on it paid two dollars for
it
that um
very first uh james bond
uh what was it
[ __ ] um
casino royale that i got was used i paid
two bucks for it it looked brand new
when it showed up
yeah i mean you can get really good
deals on like youtube yeah
a lot of times to be honest with you
like if i want to buy it like a book
and
i don't want you know i don't want to
pay like the full price for it like if
i'm not if it's an author i'm not sure
i'm gonna like all that much
you know if i'm just trying something
out then yeah i'll buy a used copy as
long as it's in like decent condition
although it doesn't have to be in that
good condition because if i leave it in
here like pookie will tear it up so
because she likes to tear up paper
but now the other day i did when we were
at
again we were at the molecule we were
seeing a movie and i went barnes and
noble and i actually did buy two books
like paperback like
full price which i don't which i haven't
done for a long time because like i said
i'm usually broke but murder hornets
said the swamp thing had a [ __ ]
series it did i remember that i didn't
remember that i don't think i watched it
but i remember it being around i
remember it being around
i mean i loved i love horror anthology
stuff i mean i love horror anthology
movies i love horror anthology tv shows
and the thing about particularly the
ones that came out in like the 70s i
kind of feel like 60s and 70s
because i grew up
reading all those alfred hitchcock
presents
anthology books
um so i got real familiar with a lot of
those authors
so i'm like really really into a lot of
horror
authors from like the 50s 60s 70s
and a lot of them like wrote for tv as
well i mean richard matheson is
obviously the most like you know the
most obvious example but there was like
another one too so like a lot of times
like we'll be watching star trek or
something like that and they'll be like
written by yada yada and be like oh my
god i've read short stories by that dude
like that was in like an alfred
hitchcock horror anthology so
you know it's kind of cool how it's sort
of like this small community of like
horror writers and their [ __ ] keeps like
turning up everywhere i don't know i
just think that's neat maybe that's me
dj maniac says i showed you the henry
and glenn forever comic a while ago
didn't i yes you did yes you did i don't
think i showed it to tom though you
would probably like really like that a
condom it's called um henry and glenn
forever and it's a comic and it's
basically like henry rollins and glenn
danzig it's like and it's super super
funny
so somebody else has made that [ __ ]
yeah made that parallel yeah they were
very similar i'm telling you man
everything that you've thought of like
somebody else on the internet is thought
of yeah dj maniac also sent me earlier
and this like made me laugh really hard
he sent me a thing earlier like somebody
had made a comment on something about
they said the most unbelievable thing
about the hunger like that 1983 movie is
that
david bowie and catherine de nov would
like need to like convince people to
like be sex murdered by them because
in real life there'd be like a line
around the block
that was like yeah exactly exactly david
bowie has the instagram
did you know that from from from beyond
the group beyond the grave wow
somebody's running it and [ __ ] um
yeah that's probably like his social
media team yeah and i follow it and
everybody bank's got to say they post
they post all kinds of [ __ ]
photographs i've never seen before
[ __ ] david bowie back in the day back
in the 70s and back in the 60s
him hanging out with people and at
parties and
and uh he was a trip man it was probably
fun to hang out with probably real fun
he seemed fun
yeah
some
some reports i've heard that said you
know back in the 70s
and 80s that that he was [ __ ]
uh and uh
it's [ __ ] and snotty and if uh
that's okay he didn't like you he didn't
[ __ ] like you and evidently he i'm
also kind of [ __ ]
he could like not he could like not like
you over nothing you know what i mean so
she just didn't like how you looked you
know what i mean and [ __ ] he didn't
know what yeah so that's not over
nothing he did have a reason yeah his
his reason was he didn't like how you
looked that kind of [ __ ] yeah well hey
how many times have we stood in
mannequins and i said i don't like that
person yeah
shorts and crocs on yes so yeah yeah
and i'm fully aware i own because that's
[ __ ] that's true yeah i'm just like i
don't even i if i could punch that dude
i would look at those [ __ ] shorts
look at those shoes yeah like why are
you dressed like that why do you look
that way yeah
you know where you are you're right
you're making yeah you're making me
angry yeah so it's like you know i know
it's shallow i know yeah that's okay i
own that that's the rules of the game
how's that i own that
i mean even
alternative club i mean why are you
going out for the night like looking
like that i didn't look at it in that
perspective though because i was
assuming that he was talking about
somebody who is like a peer of his but i
was thinking like yeah probably like we
go to the club and see a [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here like the
bitchiest people alive
you want to show up the club and [ __ ]
we're almost as bad as gays seriously
yeah
yeah that's why we like to hang out with
with the gays so much because it's like
they're as [ __ ] as we are yeah they're
super [ __ ]
well they're just in the scene too look
at what they're wearing oh my god
[Laughter]
we're very much like that
yeah
what gays are in the scene that's they
have some in this that's what i'm saying
and kind of being
goth is like its own sexual orientation
it's in a way it's like its own thing in
a way
kind of supersedes everything else
and um yeah
yeah you might have to look at a
[ __ ] gun man you're [ __ ] up
i mean that's part of the fun yeah
that's part of the fun because sometimes
especially like if i'm at a place then
like if the music isn't great because
like if the music is great i'll just
dance my ass off all night and i'm not
worried about it
unless somebody gets up in my dancing
space and then we're gonna have words or
you know or i'm gonna like elbow you or
something but if i'm just like standing
by the bar because the music is kind of
meh then that's what i'm going to do i'm
going to entertain myself by
looking at people and like critiquing
what they're wearing yeah
like if they're wearing i don't critique
other goths i'm just kind of like yeah
you're fine but if some like [ __ ]
randos come in there oh i'm absolutely
judging absolutely
john smith says another great largely
forgotten show was night stalker that's
right like cole check and they made like
two tv movies of that as well
and i remember seeing those a long time
ago
and i remember them being good but i
don't think i've ever seen the series
though
i don't think i've ever seen the series
murder hornet says the heavens gates the
heavens gate website is still working is
it really so someone must be still
maintaining they didn't all kill
themselves
no
some of the ones like pussed out
they're like yeah you guys have fun with
that no they evidently had like a
support network
there was like some kind of support
network that was going to help launch
them to the [ __ ] outer stars that
weren't really
involved in any of that
and uh weren't
i had to go back and look at the case
but no there were some of them that
did that didn't go and
some of them knew it was going to happen
and there were other ones that didn't
know it was going to happen
it's some weird [ __ ]
well i guess that's true i mean a cult
is just like any other organization yeah
in the sense that probably like some
people don't know what the [ __ ] these
other people are doing it's like you're
gonna have some people that are like way
like yeah there was more to it than that
like they thought that they would
like they had orders like yeah we're
gonna launch and we'll actually project
and [ __ ] link up with the [ __ ]
comment
and then um we'll come back to get you
it would sound like that kind of stuff
we'll come back and pick you up later
once once we're in the ship you know
what i mean [ __ ] uh we'll come back
[ __ ] we'll come back if we'll come
back and get you this it's gonna be that
kind of stuff
yeah yeah after you take care of
everything here come back in the space
we're gonna come back
yeah we'll come back in 25 years and
pick you up oh my god that kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh my god it was something like that
that's crazy somebody who might know the
case better than me but i remembered
that there were some people that didn't
go
and
yeah they didn't all go it was just like
a it was just like a porsche like i said
it didn't go and it wasn't even part of
the plan to go
that they had to stay back and run the
base type of deal
you have to bring new people right so we
can all go into space
mr88 says if they get in your space it
should be instant dance off
i'd win
i mean because the people that are all
getting up in my [ __ ] space can't
[ __ ] dance so
just saying
well you know what's weird when we were
at mannequins last friday i swear to god
i had at least like five random ass
people go you're a really good dancer
yeah like just random math people
i'm like thank you but yeah like i know
yeah he says there's a comment or an
asteroid involved yeah i can't know it
was a comment you're gonna link up with
the hail bop comment
wonder how that worked out for them
for all you know they linked up with
i mean i can't prove they didn't yeah
to their to their credit
just saying they believe that behind the
hailbot hellbop comet
in the [ __ ] tail of that comet
was an extraterrestrial spacecraft
that was using the comet as camouflage
so it could go over over the earth and
they could actually project their souls
upon death
and
link up with the [ __ ]
ufo in the comments so then they can
i guess go inside the metaverse
that was that was in the ufo
i think they believed that
we didn't have a word like metaverse and
i always imagined something like a
metaverse
a computer simulated world inside of a
computer there were your minds in it now
you call it a metaverse
they they kind of thought like i thought
that ufos and the flying triangles is
not really a ship it's more like a
computer bank inside of a
[ __ ]
spacecraft
and the entire alien species is in a
metaverse inside that thing that would
make a lot of sense because they need to
worry about biology
you don't have to worry about oxygen or
feeding them or anything they're kind of
like spirits inside of a damn computer
you know
which would be a very efficient way to
do it and then you would have to worry
about space
that i mean wouldn't have to be big it
could be small the ship and fit an
entire planet's worth of beings in it
yeah we're just going to put you on this
little yeah a little bitty thing
yeah and you're living in there and then
you're in a you're in a whole population
in this world
you're in a metaverse in a simulated
world
you know it's like a heavenly realm and
then the ship goes around you know what
i mean they got people piling it and
everything that seems like a be like the
monolith maybe the monolith was like
that
blitz phantom said yeah a former heavens
gate member still runs the site and then
mr 88 said the heavens gate site is
exactly like it was in 1997. yeah i
think when we did the show about it i
went to their website and yeah it looks
exactly it's like a 1997. like a time
capsule huh yeah it's crazy i mean
they're probably just kind of like i
mean why bother updating it
well no they probably leave it like that
for so they'll recognize it when they
come back
are they really thinking about it that
hard when the ship comes back maybe
we're thinking about it
because that's that's what [ __ ] um
[ __ ] terrible scientology has that
for l ron hubbard
all his shit's ready for him to come
back
oh my god every one of every one of the
damn big scientology bases has a house
an el ron hubbard house that they
maintain every day he's got his clothes
laid out all his cigarettes the
cigarette's ready to go
yeah yeah that was that was his
choice why do i remember that i don't
know my brain is cluttered with useless
information
isn't that well honestly isn't that the
isn't that the logo that he had kind of
like remember where he like oh yeah i
wasn't with his cools
oh that's right cool cigarette cool man
those that's right that's all cool
that's right yeah i knew it was some
brand that he had why did i say
winston's yeah
oh i know why because my grandma smoked
those that's right that's the first
thing that's not if you don't know
anything about scientology man i [ __ ]
need to go
go subscribe to a channel on youtube
called surviving scientology it's run by
um
uh
the ex-wife of one of the big leaders of
scientology
her name is karen de la carrier and
she'll tell you all and she'll have
guests on she interviews from the cult
and they will tell you some wild ass
stories i mean some of that crap like i
can't even believe that [ __ ] is real but
having
worked for scientologists and known some
scientologists i buy it yeah i buy it
there's [ __ ] some of the guests
on there were like old-time cult members
all-time church members who knew l ron
hubbard
and
l ron hubbard's [ __ ] right-hand man
who basically ran the [ __ ] ot levels
in their big schools
who was kind of like his main genius
was this black dude and he was like one
of the only black dudes in scientology
that cult is white as [ __ ]
and he was [ __ ] running
he the reason why he got into the cult
is because when he was younger he had a
spontaneous out-of-body experience
and he
always tried to reproduce it to actually
project that out of his body he never
could do it and i heard his story and i
was going yeah that happened to me it's
the exact same
he describes it perfectly
well scientology promised him to to
teach him the abilities he needed to do
to do that at will it never happened
and after he got the nose he was in
there for like 30 or 40 years
god can you imagine yeah running helping
and [ __ ] [ __ ] l ron hubbard [ __ ]
and that cult expanded a lot under this
guy's skills he was a real skilled dude
i can't remember his name off top my
head
but you can find the interview with the
guy
and he'll
and he worked for l ron hubbard for like
a couple of decades
and never met him
he never actually met him
he said he goes one day
they told me to go stand out in front of
the [ __ ] building and i was like what
the [ __ ] for just go stand out there
they told him to just obey
and as he was standing out there he
didn't know what he was standing out
there for a car came by a [ __ ]
limousine
and [ __ ] as it slowed down in front
of him and he says and i looked back in
there and i could see the old man right
there looking at me smiling at me with
his [ __ ] up old teeth and his [ __ ]
fingernails and [ __ ] and his weird fish
lips yes yeah and i saw him [ __ ] nod
and you know
and then he took over
you see the thing was is that
hubbard didn't think black people
were uh could ever absorb scientology he
didn't think they were good enough for
that yeah he thought they were dumb
racist he was [ __ ] racist and [ __ ]
big time and
he was getting all these [ __ ] daily
briefings and [ __ ]
howard was
for for years and years
and uh
he finally got curious evidently who it
was that was writing to him
you know and given him these reports he
told me it's a black guy it's like the
only black guy in scientology and he can
write
hubbard wanted to see him but he didn't
want to meet him just want to see him
and that and that happened and his and
then
[ __ ] um and he did something i can't
remember what it was he he did some kind
of big achievement that
the church has been trying to do it for
a long time he tells a story on that
channel
well the old man comes by and he says he
said his colonel sanders ass was sitting
back in there because he because [ __ ]
elrod hubbard didn't look like colonel
sanders in some way when he got older
yeah a little bit a little bit like
colonel sanders and he says he could see
him looking at me smiling and nodding
his head but it was kind of dark in the
glass and then the [ __ ] car took off
so the next day he was coming back from
a chow hall
and walked into his room and sitting on
his [ __ ] bed was a [ __ ] full was a
[ __ ] folding stock totally decked out
[ __ ] a ruger mini 14 and a whole bunch
of ammunition and just all this [ __ ]
that he liked because [ __ ] the black
dude [ __ ] loved guns
and he
ron hubbard somehow figured out what it
was he wanted and he wanted a mini 14.
gave him a mini 14. he's like santa
claus yeah yeah it's actually it was
like a mock-up of that [ __ ] ruger uh
ac556 i think what i think is what that
was called 556 was a folding stock
[ __ ] kind of
mini 14
and all kinds of [ __ ] gifts and [ __ ]
and that was his reward for something
that he did for the church and he says
that was the only time he'd ever seen
l ron howard and he didn't see he saw
him just through the [ __ ] glass that
dark and smoked glass
and then um
but he said about his astral projection
that he did that spontaneous out of body
stuff he said he joined scientology to
learn how to do that
and the more he found out about
scientology the more he realized that
scientology was the exact opposite of
what you needed in order to [ __ ]
in order to [ __ ] i mean it's pretty
much the opposite of anything like that
if you want to like live a healthy
life yeah and be happy
yeah pretty much the entire
all of that yeah um you know it's just
kind of like maybe i'll let you know i'm
gonna look up that guy so you can see
his story
the thing about it i know everybody says
oh i'd never get sucked into a cult
but one thing i was gonna say was that
any time that i think to myself man
i'm you know i'm almost 50 years old
it's like i wanted to you know
accomplish this this and this like by
this time period i haven't done it yet
and i'm still like working on it and i
was like man i just feel like useless
and i should have done more but then
i think about like documentaries i've
watched about people that got out of
scientology and some of those [ __ ]
were in there for like 30 40 years and
i'm like okay well i feel better because
they wasted
that much time in that [ __ ] so it's
like at least i didn't do that
you know that makes me feel a little bit
better like you know i'm glad they get
out i'm not saying that but
i mean
i don't know i kind of feel like the
reason well the reason that i probably
never get sucked into a cult is one i
hate people and two it's like i'm not a
joiner i don't really like i don't get
this whole thing where people are like
well i need to be accepted by other
people or i want to like hang out with i
don't
i don't [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that
i don't really i don't like any of that
kind of crap i don't want to get
involved i don't i don't want to be
involved in whatever it is you're doing
i don't need acceptance from you i don't
need any of that kind of crap so
i don't know i don't know so i don't
think that would get sucked into that
well i wouldn't have got accepted that
because i think they're weirdos
i think they're weird so i said the
scientology tried to recruit and then we
tried to give his ass the personality
test i remember that [ __ ]
i mean you guys like i don't know like
i've brought this up before
but maybe some of you guys weren't here
before i don't remember like the last
time i mentioned this but
uh back in 2002
i think it was 2002. i lived in the
tampa clearwater area like i'd grown up
in daytona beach my whole life i moved
to tampa clearwater area i had a job
over there
and i had a job i only worked there for
a month and then like i couldn't stand
it so i quit and then i ended up working
for this other place that
sort of like unbeknownst to me was owned
by scientologists it wasn't a
scientology company
but it was like a
it was actually what it was was like a
direct mail like it was kind of like you
they designed it like it was for um it
was like business to business like for
insurance companies it was basically you
were printing out
packs of
information [ __ ] for like
uh for insurance agents here's all of
these insurance packages that we have
for you to like to sell to other people
it was that kind of it was like super
boring
so i was in there like designing all
these like mail-in cards that's pretty
much what i was like these packets of
mailing cards
but it was owned by scientologists and
probably about
75 percent of the employees were also
scientologists now when i first started
working there
i didn't realize they were
scientologists when i applied for the
job um or even i don't even remember if
they brought up when i interviewed i
can't remember if they did but like when
i got the job
and when i went in there to fill out the
paperwork they're like okay well we're
all scientologists but we you know are
legally we're not allowed to like push
our beliefs on you i'm just like okay
fine whatever they did give me the
personality test which i thought was
like [ __ ] and i just like answered
whatever i thought they wanted me to
answer because i was just like [ __ ] it i
just need money i don't really give a
[ __ ] so i just did that
and then i started working there and it
was just kind of like
they
said that they weren't allowed to like
push scientology on you but they
absolutely would the first half hour of
every work day from 8 00 to 8 30 or 8 30
to 9 i can't remember
you would have to go into their
classroom which was on the first floor
and you had to do
l ron hubbard courses like his business
courses because he wrote about
everything
and i thought that these were
complete
ass i mean they were just like the
stupidest [ __ ] it was like it was really
obvious [ __ ]
mixed in with a bunch of like really
really stupid [ __ ] you know what i
mean and i was just kind of like i
really have to do this with paycheck
okay fine
like i said i got rent to pay i i had
[ __ ] to do but
when they started doing stuff like
people are in the room
making clay figures that are like
talking to each other
and i was just kind of like what the
[ __ ] is going on in here it looks like
[ __ ] romper room all right this is
the guy i was telling you about his name
is jesse prince
all right
and that was uh
one of the highest ranking members of
scientology he basically ran the church
he was ghost running the church for l
ron hubbard and in those air this he
goes way back he's like from back in the
70s and 60s and [ __ ] and he was
african-american
in a [ __ ]
and which was some weird [ __ ] because
that church
really wanted nothing to do with african
marriage at that time
nowadays they're [ __ ] with uh well
now they're desperate because they're
desperate and they're going with the
[ __ ] people they're like oh all the
white people are like on to us now right
so now they're kind of like trying to
hook up with i mean they've established
churches like in
south central and south america like
places like that because they're like
well
maybe they haven't heard how shitty we
are yeah so you can go on youtube and
sucker some people in go up on youtube
and [ __ ] go to surviving scientology
jesse prince and [ __ ] he tells a wild
ass stories and it's all true he's a
cool dude real real intelligent
oh [ __ ] real professional
and kinda
he was real talented and he he helped
bring that church
to to success
um
he kind of regrets it
slaved away and didn't didn't pay him a
[ __ ] dime
it's like
well that's kind of the whole thing yeah
that's kind of their whole thing yeah
they want people to just like work for
nothing yeah essentially what they do
it's kind of like a military environment
where you're living in barracks and
you're you know you eat through the chow
hall and they don't really feed you that
much the food isn't that good and they
just keep working you and working and
you're working you in these damn bases
and it's he was in what was called the
sea org which was their version of like
the clergy
and it's like joining the navy
everything was kind of modeled after the
navy because uh hubbard was a [ __ ]
naval captain in world war ii of a minor
ship like a i think it was an
anti-mining ship or anti-submarine ship
or something
uh he lied about his backgrounds there's
a real good movie about it called was
what's it called the wizard no uh the
master the master
yeah that's a great movie yeah the
master they couldn't come out and call
him l ron hubbard but that's who they're
talking about they didn't want to get
sued yeah yeah because uh yeah
scientologists are very sue happy yeah
they'll see the [ __ ] out of you very see
you happy
um
honestly yeah so i worked there and like
i was down there and i was like what is
up with the clay figures
and i asked one of the other graphic
designers there were five of us four of
us four of us
and i asked one of the other graphic
designers who was absolutely not a
scientologist and actually none of the
graphic designers were scientologists
now that i'm thinking about it one was
jehovah's witness but the other three
were atheists
so i was like what the [ __ ] is that
about like it looks like they're doing
like some [ __ ] wallets and gromit
yeah sly found it called life at the top
of scientology jesse prince wow yeah you
check that [ __ ] out
he's a [ __ ] he's a good dude he tells
a wild stories man and it's all true you
got
dude
senior cult members
remember the [ __ ] that he's talking
about going yep that's it [ __ ] you
know
he's just he he's a nice guy just got
wrapped up into it
but you would get wrapped up into it
back in those days before the internet
when that church was young it was a lots
of rich people in this [ __ ] church
and it's a cult and it's basically a ufo
cult
that's promising to [ __ ] t give you
mental powers like a jedi that's
basically what it is
all on the word of this [ __ ]
mysterious dude that you never see
[ __ ] called l ron hubbard
who's written all these damn books
seriously if another
human being yeah
that eats and shits and does everything
that i do comes to me and says they have
the solution to all my problems i am
telling that person to get as far away
from me as [ __ ] possible
it doesn't exist they had all these
bases and compounds spread out around
the world and in in the united states
that were
super expensive and
weird [ __ ] like secret desert bases that
had [ __ ] huge walls and barbed wire
and armed guards
[ __ ] garden underground vaults filled
with [ __ ]
holy tablets
with [ __ ] writings that were written
on [ __ ] what was it wasn't uh
platinum what was it titanium plates
and the shit's all [ __ ] sealed and
dudes are out there [ __ ] guarding it
like somebody's going to come get it
because they thought the world was going
to end so they needed they needed all
this high security
and there's gulags and prisons in there
if you [ __ ] break a church rule
they'll put you in the prisons
and you can't bust them out of the
prisons because they'll stay there they
go no i deserve it this is my religious
atonement you know
they're [ __ ] nuts
but they're not stupid in a way they're
intelligent people wrapped up into this
yeah and i would never i would never say
i mean i might have said this at some
point but
it's not necessarily stupidity it's not
stupidity that's something else
people that get sucked into cults it you
know intelligent people get sucked into
cults all the time it doesn't have
anything to do with intelligence or lack
of intelligence um
as much as it might look like that on
the surface i think it's more to do with
vulnerability versus not and
i mean how strong is your personality
how strong is your ego how strong do you
seek approval from others how you know
what i mean um do you listen to like
other people like as authorities and
stuff like that which i've never done so
i kind of feel like that's maybe why
the appeal of this doesn't
get to me but i can see how other people
could get sucked in and to be honest i
give um
a lot more leeway
to people that have been born in it
particularly like scientology because at
this point i think they're third
generation there's some people that
have you know were born in it and then
they've had kids that were born in it
too now if you were born in it and
that's all you know then obviously
that's going to be all you know so it's
just like you don't know what the world
outside is like because scientology
if you're in kind of like the inner
circle is very insular and they don't
really like you looking at anything that
is critical of scientology if you're a
public scientologist that's kind of
different
but
um there's a book that was written by
what was her name
she was actually
david miscavige's niece and she wrote a
book about she had grown up in it and it
is
horrifying that is like one of the most
horrifying and i knew all about it
because like i said i'd worked for them
and i only worked for that company for
like eight months before i was just kind
of like i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
because it wasn't just
that company but it was just that i was
living in clearwater at the time and i
don't know if you know but a lot of
clearwater florida is owned by
scientologists
so
i got to a point where
eight months in to my employment even
though like the pay was good and they
weren't really pushing their beliefs on
me
overtly but it was just kind of like
insidious
and i got to the point where i was just
kind of like look i every time i go to
the [ __ ] grocery store by my
apartment i think everybody in there is
scientologists and they're like watching
me and [ __ ] like that i was like this
isn't good this like isn't good for my
mental health i need to get the [ __ ] out
of here so i quit
and then like i moved back to daytona
for a little while where i'm from and i
was but the fact that they could do that
to me was just like it pissed me off
like a lot
and so after that happened i started
going back into the history because a
couple people that work there that have
worked there for a longer time than me
because some of the people like i said a
lot of people that worked there were
scientologists but a lot of them weren't
and they weren't real
jazz about it like they were just like
me they were just like working there for
the paycheck because the pay was
actually like pretty decent for the area
do you tell me about clear water yeah
yeah
yeah clear water is their base you told
them about that it's almost like their
capital base they took over the [ __ ]
town although they're forcing them out
now they're good they're not listening
to them like they used to they took over
the whole [ __ ] town and the cops cops
are scared of them
because they would attack you with
[ __ ] lawyers
they drive you [ __ ] crazy they bought
up every [ __ ] piece of downtown
downtown [ __ ] uh clearwater they
bought up all the [ __ ] property every
building that would come up
for sale they'd buy it
and they would force all the businesses
out so they basically owned downtown but
they're reversing that now the cult's
not as strong as it was
thankfully well it's everybody's like
included everybody knows what it is
yeah which like i said a lot of people
coming out like getting out the [ __ ] out
of there like high-ranking people and
having their own youtube channels or
having like you know um like
what's-her-face uh uh
leah reminding me yeah like coming out
and doing that show i think she did like
a huge amount of damage to them that in
south park yeah like that episode that
was making fun of that really like
mainstreamed because it was true south
park episode [ __ ] them up what they're
talking about i know actually i was like
that's that's awesome because it's like
a cartoon but it's like it's for
for the good like overall like
societally because that [ __ ] needs to be
[ __ ] killed yeah and they weren't a
joke
they weren't [ __ ] up they they were
goofy [ __ ] if you asked me
but
but they had
you know they weren't a joke they had
great abilities
they were the only
religious institution or or cult
that was able to [ __ ] infiltrate the
fbi
they would [ __ ] get people to go to
school and then go to work for the fbi
and they penetrated the fbi they had
[ __ ] it's called operation snow white
and they had what was dozens of agents
inside the fbi going through their files
and trying to find out everything that
the fbi knew about scientology and it's
because ron hubbard was paranoid he
thought the fbi was after him they
weren't fbi didn't know anything about
him really
like well now we're after you yeah yeah
they can't have him they do it they
through
his wife in jail and [ __ ] over behind it
he wasn't even man enough to [ __ ]
take the rap he blamed it all on his
wife they hit her in jail that seems
about right yeah it's way [ __ ] l ron
wood
john smith spring brings up uh going
clear yeah that was a good one too that
that documentary that was also really
good but the thing about it was that
like after i left that [ __ ] crazy ass
please because i thought
i mean i knew i wasn't going crazy i'm
like these people are crazy not me but
it's making me feel like i'm going crazy
and i don't like that feeling so i was
like i'm i gotta quit
even though the money was okay so i left
and then i started doing a bunch of
research because
i knew
that
somebody had told me like there was an
editor that worked there was his name
lyle something and he was like an older
guy he was like the only editor there
that was not a scientologist
and we would go out to lunch like
sometimes like all the
non-scientologists would go out to lunch
so we could like gossip about them so we
did that sometimes so lyle would come
with us sometimes he's like an older man
and he'd been working there for a really
long time and he's like you know
lisa mcpherson
used to
work here
lisa mcpherson if you don't know like
please google that because it's kind of
like a very famous case like if you're
talking about like scientology she like
died
in
big blue like it was big blue right
yeah yeah in clear water i had her in
prison in there basically yeah and it
was just it was this whole thing it's
it's horrific like the whole case so
they said yeah she used to work here and
like the sales manager i can't remember
what our name was but it's like that
used to be her roommate
and she he's like you know like when she
died when lisa mcpherson died a bunch of
the [ __ ] that work here and that
worked here when when i was working
there they're like they had to testify
at the trial yeah and he named like a
bunch of people i was like holy [ __ ] are
you serious he's like yeah i'm serious
he's like that he's like i was here when
that [ __ ] happened because he was like i
said he was an old man and he's like
yeah that so
they know some [ __ ] um so i looked that
up that [ __ ] up afterward it was like
[ __ ] horrifying yeah yes yeah the
sales manager and i knew her
yeah that was her roommate
yeah and they totally like she [ __ ]
died i kind of feel like
they didn't kill her directly
but they were totally iris like
indirectly responsible for those of you
who don't really don't really don't know
the deal
of what scientology is and what it
believes in
it it got religious status
it's considered to be a religion by the
federal government so it's tax exempt
it which that [ __ ] needs to be well
honestly all religious tax exemption
needs to be taken away in my opinion
yeah i'm not
religions are a business okay with this
motherfucker's really much i mean you
want to run it like a business you want
to like tell people who to vote for from
the pulpit and [ __ ] like that fine pay
taxes yeah they're all kind of like
businesses if you ask me they own
property and they're big into real
estate you're a business yep
um pay taxes like the rest right so what
what uh what scientology is about
you're gonna try to encapsulate it in a
way that
people who don't know
i gotta pee
who don't really know its scriptures and
its tenets you know what it basically
what it is is it's a ufo cult
that believes in alien possession
that your bad habits and your sins are
actually what they are as their alien
souls that are [ __ ] sucked up onto
you like parasites making you do bad
[ __ ]
if you confess your sins on a lie
detector test
you can drive those [ __ ]
things out of you like an exorcism
um and then once once they are off of
you
these alien
demons basically once they're off of you
you can start building yourself up
because you're clear you can start
building your up building yourself up
through
a what they would call
a bridge
which is different levels
and then it turns into a thing where
you're paying for the courses that you
need to have these skills to go up
through these different levels
levels of progression like you're
leveling up in dungeons and dragons all
right and what you're doing is you're
paying
you're paying to have these
[ __ ] train you into being a
wizard that's basically what it is a
space wizard you're paying to become a
space wizard
and with every one of these [ __ ]
levels you go up that you've got to pay
for
your gaming
force powers like out of star wars
the ability to [ __ ]
you know
read people's minds the ability to
[ __ ] the jedi mind trick the ability
to if something [ __ ] something if you
hurt yourself the ability to back time
up and do it again so you don't get hurt
that kind of [ __ ] and because you backed
up time and you didn't get hurt you
don't remember you see you didn't
remember that it happened
so
unbeknownst to you as a high level
scientology you're [ __ ] dying and
getting hurt all the time but you don't
remember it because you're backing up
time and fixing it and going back so
really you got killed in car accidents
three or four times you stubbed your
toes [ __ ] a whole bunch of times you
[ __ ] lost your wife a whole bunch of
times you [ __ ] lose you lost all this
money but you were able to reverse time
and do it again
and that's why you don't remember it
because you're super powerful you're
super powerful super powers
they're called ot powers they're
operating feet and powers come on
because we are all uh we're all thetans
which are like thetans are like uh souls
alien souls
and then there's things called it's just
it's ridiculous but
i gotta give elrond l lrh that's what
they call l ron hubbard they call him
lrh
i'm gonna give him some credit
when he was alive he was very popular
the cult members liked him he was kind
of a nice guy
at least to the cult he did [ __ ] up
[ __ ] to his wives
uh cheated on him and [ __ ] left to
send him to jail you know for [ __ ] he
did so to me that seems like he's not
really a nice person well he was nice to
the co
right he was nice to the cult followers
if you're only nice to some people it's
nice to the cub then that's um you're
not
he was evidently very entertaining and
charismatic he would tell all these
[ __ ] stories and that [ __ ]
made all this [ __ ] up
all right his science fiction sucked he
wasn't a good writer but he was
evidently entertaining at least the
people who were in cults thought he was
entertaining
um i will say i haven't read any of his
fiction to be fair
um i you know i haven't read it so like
i said i'm not i'm not judging
but i have read a lot of his writing in
regards to his scientology courses and i
can say right now that they are [ __ ]
in
insufferable
yeah he comes across as like very it's
very neck beardy in the sense that he
comes across very like i know everything
and this is and like some of the [ __ ]
well yeah like because i told you the
place i used to work they made you do
like a half hour quickly every single
work day five days a week half an hour
and you had to do all these courses and
i do like a [ __ ] ton of them so i got
like a bunch of scientology courses for
free
um all they did was just piss me off
more though it didn't like make me want
to join the [ __ ] i was just kind of like
holy [ __ ] how can anybody fall for this
crap but anyway so i was like doing the
[ __ ] and i'm reading it and i'm like
this dude like wrote
for a living
i don't know it's just like his attitude
it's just so it drips with like
condescension yeah and he seems to think
that he understands things
better than he actually does
um it comes across that it's very dunno
krueger in the sense that he thinks he's
like way smarter than he actually is
like you read it and you're just kind of
like
it's either like super obvious [ __ ] or
like super delusional [ __ ] yeah i don't
there's like no in between
i don't think any of the scientology
thing was actually planned all that well
no i think it was you just pulling it
out of his ass yeah big time and you can
tell that if you read it
and he had a big staff behind him that
could kind of edit his [ __ ] and get it
together and turn it keep it into keep
it into a kind of like a sellable
product
um
it is a trip man the whole scientology
story is a trip all right and then tom
cruise is involved in this [ __ ] how this
had
[ __ ] how this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they actually had a good idea they
they were living in they were living in
the hollywood
their main base was in hollywood
well their second main base they had
their main base is clearwood clear
clearwater florida that's that's really
where the organizations run out of yeah
but um that's where big blue yeah but
the big no big blues in uh uh
big blue is in uh
hollywood isn't it that's a the big blue
hospital that's hollywood i'm pretty
sure that's i think it's not
no
what it is is flag base
or staff base
is in clear water i think it's called
stat google that [ __ ] yeah flat flag
i'll look at that later
i gotta stay stay on top
the uh
in hollywood was kind of like their pr
army
and their recruitment army because
clearwater when they were there is a
sleepy
town basically city i mean it's not well
i mean it's not massive but it's part of
the tampa st petersburg clearwater it's
a big metropolitan area
but clearwater itself was kind of like
more like a sleepy beach town but like i
said it's it's very adjacent to like
tampa and st petersburg which are like
much bigger cities in the day that they
in the day that they uh started working
on it there wasn't very much there
i mean there was stuff but it was no
nothing nothing compared to l.a or
or hollywood area you know that's pretty
densely populated
so this is more of like a port slash
resort area place where you go down
there and get some clams
i mean it has a nice ass beach yes beach
honestly if you're gonna go to beaches
like the west coast of florida like the
beaches are gorgeous like on the gulf of
mexico
like prettier than the east coast
beaches i think so
i forgot i was getting anyway tom they
decided that
they decided that
for a church to really grow you have to
have [ __ ]
real
um
[ __ ] high caliber members
and they were thinking celebrities and
actors so they started to [ __ ] open
[ __ ] up in hollywood where they were
and they wanted to recruit well-known
actors and actresses
and then they wanted to [ __ ] take
unknown actors and actresses and try to
make them into known
uh stars
so once they're famous in front of
everybody they could become a publicly
known scientologist which would
raise
the uh
uh the social status of the church yeah
because churches are always about social
they knew what they were doing
although i will say like nowadays i kind
of feel like your highest profile
scientologist like yeah tom cruise he's
getting older now probably the highest
profile one now it's probably like
elizabeth moss i feel like now i think
she might have been born into it yeah so
that's something else and i love her but
i don't really get like how she she
doesn't talk about scientology yeah
people don't realize there are several
generations of these [ __ ] born that's
what i was saying earlier i think
i think it's on like the third
generation now yeah right yeah
so people were kind of like
mystified behind the tom cruise things
and i've listened on that channel that i
recommend surviving scientology it has
jesse prince show on there that's the
one you want to go go for surviving
scientology youtube
there's a lot of interviews and a lot of
stories of [ __ ] people that came up
and know the whole tom cruise story they
worked behind the scenes to make certain
things happen oh they'll tell you the
whole story is about tom tom's not on
there of course okay
but there were people that were around
when all that was happening high regular
scientologists
they don't say everything about the tom
cruise situation i think they kind of
keep certain things private
but they claim that
they recruited tom cruise early on it's
around the time where he did days of
thunder around that time
and they told him that they could help
him with his career and what did mimi
rogers get him into that yeah something
like that i think that was his first
wife right i think so
and the the major thing that they said
about tom is that they said
um
that they could help him with his
problems and that his main problem they
claimed was dyslexia yeah he was just
and i don't know if that's a code word
for be illiteracy or what i don't know
okay
it may have been
um because just because the dude's
famous doesn't mean that [ __ ]
can read
it just doesn't
um
but there's a lot of things that i've
heard about tom cruise i heard that tom
cruise could
memorize a script
just
on one reading and would would remember
everything he had a real good memory he
was very intelligent
my theory is is that he had a good
memory he was intelligent but he'd never
really learned how to read that well
i think they just taught him how to read
now what they do is during the uh
during your um
what do they call it when you got a
[ __ ] when you're auditing auditing is
kind of like their version of exorcism
or prayer you got to hold these [ __ ]
electric [ __ ] cans it's like a
primitive lie detector test
during that time they're recording it
all
so during your confessions they get a
lot of dirt on you and once they have
all this dirt on you
you can't leave because then they'll
[ __ ] make that [ __ ] public yeah
so
now tom cruise doing all this [ __ ] he
did get like the best of the scientology
treatment i mean they made whole bases
behind him
him and his girlfriends they'd make a
damn base
and they'd plant whole fields of flowers
and [ __ ] when he was getting married
what was that that girl that uh she's a
cool kid nicole kidman well they were
trying to sucker her in yeah to get him
she was like no thanks when nicole
kidman started
getting into the [ __ ] tom cruise
tom was having scientology did think
making whole apartments for him with
[ __ ] fields and
whole [ __ ] tennis courts and
flowers everywhere and all these
romantic hot spots for them to go to all
these [ __ ] scientology bases him in
the cult
so they were trying to build this
[ __ ] scientology super couple
which which she would have been like the
female version of [ __ ] tom cruise i
think had she been along with
you know
because she did kind of she still she
does have the star power
of tom cruise well she's still [ __ ]
famous nowadays she's still a-list
nowadays yeah
so i love that she was just kind of like
nope she eventually said no
i've seen interviews with her you know
on other shows where she's like she
wasn't into it that she's like nah i
don't want to be around everything
everything's blamer everything was real
carefully managed
you know
and it was kind of like tom had all
these damn handlers and all these
scientology handles can imagine how
[ __ ] exhausting that would yeah i
just can't
i kind of i don't know like the reason
that i can't get into i couldn't get
into scientology i can't get into like
any of that kind of [ __ ] one i don't
like being told what to do by anybody i
don't care who the [ __ ] you are but like
i said anybody that thinks they have all
the answers or it's like oh i have this
thing oh i'm gonna give you this special
thing no you're not no you're not you're
just a [ __ ] person like me you don't
know any better than i do and honestly
you don't know like you don't know me so
it's like how would you know what i
needed better than what i know i'll
figure my own [ __ ] out thank you very
much
thank you very much well when tom
started getting into church you know
the ceo of the church is david miscavige
he's about he's about the same age as
tom and they're about the same size
these little short [ __ ] five
five five six five seven that's maybe
even shorter i think david miscavige is
five four eddie i think he's a little
bitty dude so he's like he's he's only
like a inch taller than me yeah and i'm
pretty miniature
[Laughter]
and i'm only about five two five three
yeah
and uh being a short guy myself [ __ ]
when you get too many short guys
together in [ __ ] one spot all of a
sudden there's [ __ ] it's like little
people like midgets
we got friends who are also dwarves
those
it's it's a cross between a hate it's a
bunch of haters
and it's also kind of like a short guy
mafia well it's like an insecurity like
ego kind of like everybody has to be
they start trying to one-up each other
like that [ __ ] this and that
fragile melee it's just like it's not
fragility it's just
when you get due to her peers they start
to [ __ ] bond and compete
simultaneously
and and the source of so many problems
it's just the way it is it's just the
way it is
so it's part of the animal kingdom just
chill out man so it's all right so
see she look
[Laughter]
tom and davis miss cabbage who's the
[ __ ] who's running this [ __ ] church
kind of become these weird friends
and tom is like today is basically the
official second in command i guess you
could say the unofficial second in
command of scientology whatever tom
cruise says the [ __ ] scientology's
going to do it
every time i see the two of them
together and hanging out right
motorcycles the juiciness is like
i can't even like deal with the
douchiness
they're both douchey on their own i mean
obviously david miscavige is like way
like way too short a hundred times more
douchey than tom cruise but tom cruise
is pretty douchey too so like when they
get together it makes like this black
hole of douchiness and i just can't i
can't deal with it it's it's too much
there's some kind of weird synergy going
on
where david miscavige kind of secretly
wants to be tom cruise
you know he wants to be why don't they
just [ __ ] already and just like leave
the rest of us alone i mean unless they
have already and then secretly they
should then tom cruise actually kind of
wants to be the leader of scientology so
he kind of wants to be david and this
camera they all they want to beat each
other
they just need to [ __ ] and when
and and i'm telling you this because
in that [ __ ] movie that came out the
scientology made called battlefield
earth which i love that movie just i
love that movie it's goofy as [ __ ] it's
terrible it's goofy [ __ ] [ __ ] it but
it's [ __ ] funny and i like it i like
it
i mean it's so bad the star of the show
features that an actor that looks just
like david miscavige looks just like him
what's that what's that actor's name
just like david miscavige the star of
that show
um
[ __ ] some of you guys can drop that in
there
but especially at that time you could
put david in this cabbage and that actor
side by side and they would look the
same
which i was thinking to myself dave
miscavige wants to be a movie star like
tom cruise of course that [ __ ]
wants to be a movie star like i said
fragile egos man
and then like david miscavige talking
[ __ ] about tom cruise behind his back
like he's a [ __ ] dork you know what i
mean
miss cabbage thinks [ __ ] tom cruise
is a dork even though spoiler alert
both dorks that [ __ ] are those
[ __ ] are in love with each
other why don't they just [ __ ] leave
the rest they're in love with each other
seriously and then like you guys just
[ __ ] each other and shut up and we'll
leave you alone
it'll all be fine it's a win-win
anyway um
then we don't have to hear about it
anymore
but you know i'm [ __ ]
jenny's jenny's hard on him but i know
how dudes are i think it's just [ __ ]
polite well i mean it's hilarious like
to me it's hilarious as a as a woman as
um
[Music]
like our patience for like dudes
shenanigans is already just like this
big
and like the older you get like the it
just it's smaller and smaller and
smaller until you get to a point where
you're old you're just like oh my god i
just can't [ __ ] i can't deal so can't
deal anymore but let me clear the air in
case tom's [ __ ] watching
i'm sure tom cruise is watching
our [ __ ] obvious i'm just gonna say
12 000 subscribers
i'm gonna say that [ __ ] no i respect
tom cruise's work as an actor i respect
his work he was in some good shape but
i'm not saying that i'm not [ __ ] on
him like across the board no i told you
he was great in
magnolia he was great in the interview
with the vampire he's great in some [ __ ]
right and here's here i like the mission
impossible movies hey
here here's my grand
theory
as to why tom cruise is a scientologist
and why he's been in scientology and why
he likes it
tom cruise
came from humble background made a [ __ ]
ton of money got real famous in [ __ ]
movies
but his job was to pretend
to be these exciting
characters and to be this dude that
could drive cars and [ __ ] fly jet
planes and [ __ ] shoot guns and do all
this macho [ __ ] but it's just pretending
and that wasn't good that's not good
enough like i said he's different he
wanted it wasn't good enough he wanted
the real thing he wanted to do it okay
now he can't join the army he's [ __ ]
tom cruise he can't join the army he
never you know i mean [ __ ] he's
famous he'd be losing out on all kinds
of money elvis did but david but that
was the time when you got drafted yeah
okay you can't join the i just thought
it'd be an [ __ ] so
going to scientology was kind because it
has a paramilitary kind of a flavor to
it
him credentials and training and stuff
that he needed
to
at least in his own mind give himself
the uh credentials
okay which
probably true because uh scientology
scientology gave tom cruise things that
it wouldn't give it normal
well i mean some people really need
the whole hierarchical
i'm moving up a chain
and i need people like to officially
like say that i'm over these people
right i don't have that so i don't get
it but it's like some people like a lot
of people do have that i get it they're
giving him some paranormal type [ __ ]
training you know what i mean he's got
mental skills like a jedi or whatever
but i think he's also doing things like
he really really can't ride motorcycles
he really can't fly aircraft he really
is good with a gun yeah
kicking ass right now top gun too is
kicking [ __ ] ass and i'm sure it's
good we still haven't seen it we have to
see if we will see it but i've heard
it's yeah i've heard it's amazing yeah i
wanted to see it everybody every yeah
thing that i've seen said it was amazing
and [ __ ] um i love the whole mission
impossible series and i'm gonna think
we're good and i'm a big james bond the
later ones were good i didn't love the
version it got better as it went it did
actually it got better as it went on i
liked them more as like they got and i'm
a huge bond fan i like the [ __ ]
daniel craig bonds i [ __ ] love them
and [ __ ] uh cruz and his little team
there
uh took mission impossible and made it
competitive against that yeah and it and
it's probably agree with that yeah fall
out was great that last one yeah i think
there was another one after that
but the like the last three
fall out in the theater yeah
i likes that a lot yeah the last three
on that series were really good last two
or three they were as good as the james
bond move
so
i'm not making fun of tom tom's [ __ ]
he just took a different path i just
kind of goofed a little bit on on the
church that that church is [ __ ]
bad to the average person it it's i mean
to him it probably like works for him
but the thing about it is that
but they're not they're not about the
average [ __ ] well the thing
about any [ __ ] church is about
exclusivity and you're not good enough
to be a scientologist which is okay
that's fine but
they're clergy in the sea org they treat
them like [ __ ] dirt
and
it's kind of a scam on them
uh it's like
military service but without any kind of
pay and without the [ __ ] legitimacy
of military service right because if you
tell your people oh i'm ot8 or whatever
that's going to be like give a [ __ ]
about that who [ __ ] cares okay you
run a call good for you you just spent
like 400 000 on some [ __ ] that doesn't
mean anything good for you i guess my
thing is is that tom would have been
great without scientology
that's what i'm saying and it's like
well that's what i'm that's what makes
me mad right
it's like you don't need that yeah
i don't think he would have been you
don't need that right that's what makes
me angry about it like i get why people
get sucked into cults i do like i said i
probably wouldn't because like i said i
hate people and it's like i don't you
know
if i can be around as few people as
possible that's like good with me i
don't like being told what to do i don't
like being like having to explain
anything that i'm doing i'm just
anything
so
i don't i'm not a joiner i don't i don't
really like that
so
but i get that like other people are
kind of like in particular people that
are really vulnerable and i feel like a
lot of churches and cults and stuff like
that they know
that people are vulnerable like because
they have you know trauma in their past
or they're drug addicts or something
like that so it's like we're gonna
target those kind of people what
scientology does with narconon uh you
know there's other kind of stuff like
that we're going to like bring in all
these people that have other problems
and then we're going to like present oh
we have a solution to your problems xyz
and then they're going to like suck you
into it and that's
just replacing one addiction with
another i really think it's bad but
you know i'm not if they're adults i
can't really like tell them what to do
but it just like makes me really really
sad when i see people like falling into
[ __ ] like that because it's like
i know it's hard but you really just
kind of have to figure your own [ __ ] out
nobody knows [ __ ] nobody knows you
better than you do you know what i mean
and i know some people need outside help
and i'm not [ __ ] on that like if you
need that then absolutely get that but
i'm just saying that a lot of times a
[ __ ] cult especially one like
scientology that's gonna charge you like
all the [ __ ] money
you know you're gonna spend up like 30
000 or whatever the [ __ ] it is and
they're gonna like enslave you and [ __ ]
like that don't fall into that kind of
crap because they cannot help you they
really can't maybe they can help you in
the short term but in the long term that
is going to be really really bad
you're you're just replacing one
addiction with another you know what i'm
saying it's like that really really
makes me angry it really makes me angry
i just really wish people wouldn't fall
for it but you know i see how people do
and they know that
that's why they target vulnerable people
you know and that just makes me really
really mad because it's just it's very
very cynical
because the fact that sciento not just
scientology but like
cults in general and religions in
general uh do target
vulnerable people yeah because they know
that they're open to that kind of [ __ ]
because they're looking for something to
like plea you know please help me yeah
and it's like that's shitty tom tom
wanted to be in some kind of an
organization to give him [ __ ] street
cred and official documentation that's
what i thought
and they gave him good training he
probably got the best they could ever
give him well and he was a lot of the
[ __ ] that he ended up that made him
[ __ ] good did
he would have got that anyway
that's what i'm saying he didn't need
that he didn't need that
that's what kind of like pisses me off
about it
but you know john gore says we all come
under the spell of some kind of [ __ ]
or other i mean you know i guess that's
just like a human thing i get it but
don't fall into a spell of [ __ ]
that's gonna like charge you a hundred
thousand dollars to like tell you you
can have jedi powers just you know
that's my pro tip
because that's
i don't know i i guess i'm like
particularly salty about like [ __ ]
scientology because i had to spend eight
months of my life like looking at their
stupid [ __ ] faces like every day of
the week and it just like it made me
really really
really really mad about them like and
the thing about it was that
i was gonna say earlier the company that
i work for
one weird thing was that
you know yeah a lot of people there like
were scientologists or they were like
older but there was a new generation
working there too and they were like in
managerial positions and some of them
were like 16 they had grown up in the
[ __ ] and that was all they knew they
didn't know
anything normal like you couldn't have a
normal conversation with them about like
normal [ __ ] because
you would talk to them about like movies
or any kind of like cultural kind of
reference or anything like that and they
had no idea what you were talking about
like the one girl that was like she was
uh she was like the hr manager i think
and she was 16
and she was working at this company and
i was talking to her one day like i
tried to avoid like talking to her but i
was talking to her one day about
something and it's like i'm talking
about just [ __ ] that i don't even
remember what it was but [ __ ] that
everybody would know like if you were a
normal person she had no idea what i was
talking about no idea
and they had like this weird like blank
stare when they were looking at you but
then like they call it conversely
they thought that they were smarter than
you yeah which was like infuriating
because it's like they would talk to you
and they were idiots and they didn't
know anything
but then they would also like project
this real superiority kind of just like
oh my god don't even do that [ __ ] to
me don't do that to me i i think i hate
that more than anything else in the
world dumb [ __ ] pretending like
thinking they're smarter than you oh my
god i hate that so much and it's like
when that came across to me i was just
kind of like i'm okay i got i'm leaving
i'm leaving i have to go to like the
other office right now bye
[ __ ] 16 year old talking to me that
doesn't know [ __ ] about anything right
and it's like acting like they're so
much smarter than me and i'm just like
okay
i'm gonna get i'm gonna hit you so i'm
gonna let go in the other room it was
like that
ugh that's why i had to leave i was like
i'm gonna [ __ ] murder all these
[ __ ] i hated it
now grandpa's going back to saying that
all the tom cruise grabbed this [ __ ]
and he's in the house all right
grandpa's saying that all his exes says
that he got to be too much kidman
penelope i can see that oh yeah
[ __ ] he he he grows and grows
and forces you out he's he's a
probably drive you [ __ ] crazy
well he drives me crazy and i don't even
know the dude right so i can imagine
he's never been around anybody to tell
him no problem that if you knew him
intimately like you had to put up with
him for like however many hours in the
day i've never been around around
anything man probably that would be
exhausting i'd be exhausted after an
hour he's never been around anybody that
can tell him no or any regular guys or
nobody they can [ __ ] slap him
he's got always had the power to kick
people out of the get out of it get out
of here you know security and stuff so
you know
well i mean
kind of like a child you know i mean if
anybody ever like wants anybody to
volunteer to slap him i'll do it
[Laughter]
i'll do it yeah just saying i mean i'm
sure there's probably going to be a long
line but i'll do it
he needs a good slap
just saying
it's too late he's sucking he's ossified
he's [ __ ] frozen i mean he's older
than we are so i kind of and i'm i don't
want to say like you know people can
change whatever age they are but
generally the older you get the more you
get stuck in your ways everybody's
saying the top gun too is great i want
to see it
i am not spooky will you holy [ __ ] what
are you doing
she's racing invisible she's like what i
wasn't yeah racing invisible things
she thinks there's like an invisible
thing in here yeah yeah she's like
and then she's like i like submission
impossible too yeah i like them i did it
yeah i liked all these even that old one
you know with the j i didn't like the
first one i liked the the they were
different it was a little goofy they
were different but as they got more like
the james bond one
james bond movies i was more into it
well one of them was the john woo movie
like a and it had that [ __ ] kung fu
style
filter i think it was part two i think
it was mission possible too
it was john woo remember him
yeah i know who he is wait did i see the
second one
you showed me the first one but i think
i fell asleep because i was like oh this
is goofy as [ __ ] i don't like this yeah
and i think i fell asleep there were
movies of their time but then they
started to update and they kind of yeah
i think uh casino royale forced them to
change they're like yeah we need to go
more what bond is doing yeah and yeah
that was the right decision yeah
uh mega says cruz is one of the last big
stars maybe the last one he is also a
very good actor given the right script
yes he is yeah he can act and collateral
he was great
yeah you create an assassin
he makes a good villain he's a real good
because like i said that leans into his
natural assholery
which they he should do that more often
he's a good villain yeah
i should show you magnolia it's like
it's it's
it's an indie film but he kind of plays
a douche in that one too and he's
excellent
he's a good excellent when he plays a
dude he's a good villain um but he he's
a good hero too but he could do both uh
also when he plays somebody who's kind
of like
in between like uh in [ __ ] eyes wide
shut
he wasn't a bad guy but he wasn't a good
guy either he was kind of a [ __ ]
dick in a way yeah he's kind of a douche
in that one yeah yeah
well the thing okay
i liked him in eyes wide shut kind of
although i mean i like that movie it's
not my favorite stanley kubrick
obviously but it's good you know it was
a good movie i like i appreciate it more
like the more times i've seen it
the thing i don't like about tom cruise
playing
heroes
particularly in films like
maybe not so much the new top gun
because i haven't seen it but like the
original top gun stuff like that where
he's playing like a very obvious like
i'm the hero of the movie
that's the problem i have is that he
comes across very much like i'm the hero
of this movie
look at my cool ass smile and he's like
very very cocky and it's just like i
don't know that just irritates the [ __ ]
that's kind of his brand though i know
but that well i that's one of the
reasons i don't like him because it
irritates him i thought he was a good
lestat even though he doesn't he was he
doesn't match what was described in the
book but he was good to stop because the
stats are [ __ ] dick right
and i think that's why that worked like
initially when i first heard about it
like many people were just kind of like
tom cruise is listed no thank you
but then when i saw the movie i'm like
oh actually okay that works yeah that
works because yeah lestat was kind of a
douche so i think that worked like i
said she was a dick yeah i mean like i
said that kind of works because it
he's and he just has this natural kind
of an arrogant cocky [ __ ] arrogant
which i hate i hate that in real life
and i don't really like and i every
single role he plays
it comes across
and so that's why i say like a lot of
the roles that he plays he just seems
like he's playing him because he just
seems like he's that person so i kind of
feel like it's better when he plays a
bad guy
because then it kind of like just leans
into it yeah
yeah i'm an [ __ ] well you see i'm a
bad guy
i get i grew up
under the influence of other kind of
movies i think as a kid
when tom cruise first started to peer
like in days of thunder and all that
[ __ ] you know when i was [ __ ]
spending summers out in mississippi
to me i instantly recognized it as a
younger version of of of um
like gator you know what's his name uh
burt reynolds bert reynolds had that too
yeah but that wasn't his intense and
bert reynolds could laugh at himself
that was i think that was the main
difference like burt reynolds laughed at
himself he never pissed me off because
he never came across
as
arrogant like he maybe there was a
little bit of arrogance and cockiness
but
he was always kind of charming and he
was like a little bit self-deprecating
yeah he'd make fun of him so he could
kind of like deflate like the balloon a
little bit yeah of his ego yeah and that
appealed him to me more tom
it feels like can't really do that he
takes himself a little bit too seriously
yeah and i think that's what's
that's what's jarring to me and that's
what's that's what i don't like about
him if y'all haven't seen gator one and
two see it burt reynolds
batman burt reynolds action movie and
they were southern movies made for the
south for the southern market it was
white exploitation
just as good as black exploitation or
honky splay the honk exploitation all
right
yeah anyway
or crackers please cracker cracker
exploitation all right
it was kind of like a rudy ray moore
flick
uh but not comedy yeah there was comedy
in it but
more of a mix not quite as low budget
not as long as more but it had money
holy [ __ ] when we were at fye a couple
weeks ago they had a whole box set of
all the rudy raymore movies yeah i think
it was like 110 dollars but it was a
whole bunch of movies all right i was
tempted i was tempted because i like
rudy more flicks
they're good they're good movies they're
[ __ ] funny i mean they're terrible
but they're super interesting no they're
good they're good they're they're kind
of like that's what that's uh where
eddie murphy was inspired yeah i mean
you could tell that that's where eddie
murphy was coming from he was trying to
have his own version of a rudy ray moore
flick i mean there's a [ __ ] huge a
murphy fan going back to the golden
child and [ __ ]
[ __ ] bear the hills cop axel foley
was one of my favorite characters
growing up [ __ ] you know axe
you know the [ __ ]
and you know what the movies still hold
up one and two holds up three never held
up
and evidently well it was kind of [ __ ]
yeah it wasn't
it was
just the tone was wrong
and the writing wasn't as good
um
you could tell but it was just kind of
thrown together kind of quickly
but evidently um
rumor has it that eddie is making
a [ __ ] axel foley comeback flick and
yeah i heard that
um and that's one of his favorite
characters so that [ __ ] i'm thinking
it's going to be good because coming to
america too was good
um
yeah it was it was good it was good it
wasn't as good as one no but it has a
good thing man [ __ ] uh but it was it
was pretty when the king died and [ __ ]
he he had his own he was present at his
own funeral
i did like that to me like i laughed the
reason why two wasn't why coming to
america two wasn't as good as one is
because coming to america two was pg
that was that was the reason coming to
america one was a rated r
all right that that
you kind of want a rated r type of deal
but they were they went a little bit
more the thing about it though is that
like nowadays is there really any
because most people don't see [ __ ] in
the theater anyway so it's like is there
really any reason to make [ __ ] pg-13
they wanted to hit the family [ __ ]
market [ __ ] yeah that evidently went
well for for um
that was uh and kids today have seen
everything yeah don't worry they
shouldn't worry about it don't [ __ ]
worry about it
jesus christ actually even back in the
[ __ ] late 70s and 80s i had seen like
way worse [ __ ]
than [ __ ] movies nowadays so it's
like don't worry about it they'll be all
right they'll be okay it's just a movie
mango says it was shockingly bad no it
was not shockingly bad go ahead man it
was it was it wasn't it was it was good
okay it was okay i enjoyed it but like
it was it was pg that was the problem
yeah it seemed a little uh it was a
little too it was a little bit
neutered yeah but i wouldn't mind it
look [ __ ] y'all
all right i like vampire in brooklyn
i thought that was a good that was gonna
i liked me i liked brooklyn
i hate that movie yeah a lot of people i
love vampire vampire i wouldn't mind him
coming back to to to play that character
again
i thought that was a good movie oh it's
a good vampire movie yeah this is as
good as black and then screaming back at
the screen it was funny at certain
points you know and [ __ ] but it had a
good mixture it had it had had a romance
i saw that [ __ ] in the theater
it was i was the only one watching it
but i mean one other person in the
theater a little younger tom in there by
himself not with that young i was out of
the army when that came out well you
were younger than you are now though it
was around 95.96 yeah that was a long
time ago yeah
so you were a little bit i had fun at
the theater watching it and then uh i
was happy that eddie had come back
to be honest if i have to see a movie in
a theater
um i would rather there be nobody else
in the theater
another one that i saw in the theater
almost by myself was uh uh [ __ ] um
uh
what's his name
the frighteners
and i love him yeah yeah the frighteners
with michael j fox yeah
and it had man the frighteners is so
good i kind of feel like well
i know but i mean that was 96. yeah but
i feel like nowadays i mean me like
watching all the horror channels and
stuff like that i feel like most people
are like really into that movie now so i
feel like it took a long time to find
its audience yeah good movie well
the thing about it's like a paranormal
version well it's peter jackson it's
peter jackson yeah like if you guys
don't know lord of the rings blah blah
blah yeah uh he started out in horror
like dude dead alive if you haven't seen
dead alive uh please see that it's the
goriest movie ever made i i don't think
there's any
competitor for that crown
um and it's also one of the most
entertaining like gorflicks that i've
ever seen
i don't think you've seen it have you
dad alive no oh you probably said he'd
never seen vampire brooklyn oh you got
to see that one oh it's good it's fine
yeah it's good good
but the thing about it is that
horror comedy
or black comedy is always a hard sell
i'm not sure why that is
it's just that it's not like really
widely palatable i guess
the frighteners
the tone is kind of all over the place
um
but
so maybe like some people are like well
is this supposed to be horror is it
supposed to be comedy is it suppose and
like some people like that turn people
off
at the time
but nowadays people like get what he was
trying to do
you know what i mean yeah i kind of feel
like that's a really hard
black comedy seems like it's really
really hard to sell always imagine if
back to the future was a horror movie
and it had a cast that you [ __ ] dug
and and that's what that movie is if you
ask me
it's got michael j fox
he's kind of playing marty mcfly but
he's older and the motherfucker's got a
past
and he's a little cynical yeah
he lost his wife and he's kind of
[ __ ] down and out
and he's a paranormal investigator
who's built in the [ __ ] town because
he can see ghosts
and he's got some friends that are
ghosts
and he's sending these [ __ ] ghosts to
go bother people and they're [ __ ]
then they call
frank frank he's gonna come and he's
gonna he's gonna [ __ ] be like the
ghostbusters and he's gonna get his
[ __ ] money and move on and try to
build his dream house to finish
construction on his house and his wife
got killed and he was kind of involved
in his wife's death all right he's kind
of guilty about it
and then he's got [ __ ] three ghosts
four ghosts
he's got the hanging judge oh what's his
name judge what's his name [ __ ] back
in the old west
he's [ __ ] funny his ectoplasm is all
dried up
[Laughter]
this old [ __ ] brainy [ __ ]
poindexter [ __ ] from the 20s who
hung himself is another ghost
and then uh a 1970s pimp is a [ __ ]
big old afro is his third ghost
i can't remember his name
i mean the frighteners is so good yeah
it's so good and he usually like i said
and a dog ghost is the fourth one the
dog ghost like i said
it's not but you're in if you're into
like genre bending stuff like it's not a
horror movie although it has horror
elements it's not a comedy although it
has funny [ __ ] in it yeah and it's it
kind of straddles that line
i think people didn't know what to make
of it because it was fun it was a ghost
honestly you know what one i did a
review
not too long ago of a movie called odd
thomas yeah that
you would probably dig because it was
very similar in tone to the frighteners
it came out in
2014 2015. something like that it was
based on dean coons book um anton
yelchin was in it like he was in the new
star trek movie he passed away he was
very young he died in like a weird freak
accident
but he was in it
and um it was a similar
kind of thing like a dude that could see
ghosts and stuff so you'd probably be
into that too
well on frighteners frank banister to do
the [ __ ]
michael j fox plays
in his paranormal adventures building
money out of the good [ __ ] people of
the town that he lives in
runs across the [ __ ] ghost that's
killing people
it's a ghost of a serial killer
and that's where the adventure [ __ ]
begins
and frank's starting to take the rap
they think frank's killing these people
and there's another ghost out in the
cemetery it's the ghost of a [ __ ]
marine drill sergeant played by arleigh
irving his whole job is to keep
[ __ ] in their graves all right
all kinds of funny get your graves
you shall not [ __ ] bother the people
of the game can we also talk about how
jeffrey combs is jeffrey that's right
the fbi gets involved and he's kind of
like channeling hitler a little bit
[Laughter]
he uh the fbi gets involved okay so they
send a pair they send one of their
[ __ ] cult paranormal i love
specialists
and he plays this special agent
dad versus his name yeah it's one of his
best [ __ ] characters i mean he's so
fair
i love it all right he's [ __ ] he's
he said he spent 20 years [ __ ]
working with cults and paranormal and
he's trying to figure out whether [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] banister's doing
and jeffrey comes is the [ __ ] beat
[ __ ] is weird as [ __ ] god damn
it and he makes such i love jeffrey i've
seen combs on [ __ ] uh as guests on
podcasts before he's in on youtube shows
he's a [ __ ] great guest and he drinks
through the whole [ __ ] thing and i
would love to have combs on but you want
to do you want to try to get home get a
hold of oh my god if we could get
jeffrey combs on the show oh yeah did
you ever come to be off oh my god we'll
sit down with you i would be so stressed
out because i'd be like oh my god i have
to like have to
think of all these like cool questions
like ask him
yeah you have to write up a whole
[ __ ] thing i would i would be like
nerdy we will have a [ __ ] calm show i
would have such anxiety i'll get him on
i can get him up
i know i can get him off [ __ ] love
jeffrey combs yeah
let's see what he's promoting and what
show because he's he was doing an edgar
allen poe thing remember he was touring
with edgar allan poe shows [ __ ] and
you you know all about poe that's right
so we get [ __ ] combs i did a whole
board game we'll drink together because
uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] wants to be on for a while
where he can drink and he he he wants to
get up and go take a leak like me and
get him
on the show
but uh oh my god can we get him on the
side track straight when we'll get drunk
and we'll just
[ __ ] talk oh my god we'll talk about
edgar allan poe and horror movies yeah
we'll get him on
if if the audience wants fun it would be
so stressful because we've had we've had
we've had pretty well known guests on
before it's just that's not normally the
show
it takes time to arrange it we gotta
[ __ ] technically get everything the
streaming correct and everything
and uh we could live stream it but if
you guys want [ __ ] jeffrey combs on
we can we can do it
just drop it in the comment section i
mean he seems so [ __ ] awesome he'd be
a cool guest i'd sit there and talk
every other like show that i've seen him
on like he seems like
delightful yeah he just seems like
delightful
and i loved everything like i've seen
him and he's like so weird and i love it
i love it um they're talking about
fright night
what's that friday friday night friday
night's a good one yeah linwood's size
says friday night i see every year
because of the comedy yeah i mean fright
night
you would like brighteners if you like
friday night honestly fright night i
think is one of my favorite
films from the 80s easily one of my
favorite horror comedies
i mean everything about that i must have
seen that like a million times it's
funny it's scary
it's entertaining
[ __ ] man like not last halloween but the
halloween before i dress up like amy
from fright night i had the wig and the
dress and everything
so you know
i love that
sly if you've never seen vampire in
brooklyn you need to see that man
um because what they're homaging in the
way is blacula blaculand's green black
of the screen it's very similar both of
which are fantastic which are both real
good fantastic films yeah i got them
both
um
but uh
yeah [ __ ] you you want to see vampire
in brooklyn all right it's
it's like back in the
but it has some comedy there's some
comedic
characters in it
but
eddie plays a vampire in there and it's
uh he's good man he's like
he's serious he plays it straight
i don't think he does any comedy as the
vampire that's what i remember
i mean it's been a while kind of goes
bella lugosi slightly
yeah a little like bella goes
he was a vampire that came from
somewhere out i think it was in haiti
wasn't he like a haitian vampire oh [ __ ]
i can't remember like any situation like
it's either haitian or jamaican he cut
he came from one of those islands and um
he went he comes to the united states
to look for uh for to look for a bride i
think wouldn't it
or what i can't remember why he came
maybe you're thinking of coming to
america no he came in on that ship
but then he saw that woman that's right
remember
yeah maybe it's almost like a dracula
thing where it's like it was a
reincarnation reincarnation of his wife
and try it or reincarnation of his queen
i can't remember exactly i've seen so
many like vampire movies that like lose
78 is when underwriter in stranger
things four yes she is
uh haven't really kept track of that
show after season two uh i mentioned
earlier that i had seen i watched i was
very excited like stranger things
because i really like stranger things
but sorry
but um i watched the first four episodes
i think there's still three left that i
haven't watched yet i just haven't got
around to it but the first four are like
really good it's weird watching those
kids grow up though now they're like
[ __ ]
teenagers and stuff it's like super
weird
but yeah
uh let's see uh fairly okay i'll rent
vampire in brooklyn tonight after the
podcast yeah it's good i really liked it
yeah i mentioned okay so strong 78 said
i mentioned this like earlier on the
show like when we first started kate
bush is apparently blowing up again
after stranger things four yeah and
that's the thing like i was watching
the first few episodes of
the fourth season and i was like ooh
running up that hill because i love that
song i've had it on my phone for like
forever i used to like listen to it when
i was out exercising and stuff and i was
just kind of like holy [ __ ] that song
came out at 85.
and so i love that they used it i didn't
realize
that
it had this huge cultural impact we went
to mannequins last friday
and the dj paul like played the song and
i was like whoa oh goodie like kate bush
and i was like dancing to it and then
like a couple days later like i read an
article about how kate bush
they were asking her for like her
uh you know statement about well how do
you feel about being in the top 10 again
after all of this time because that song
came out like 1985 and it's like how do
you feel about that and she's like uh
yeah it's like pretty awesome because i
can imagine
but i thought that was really cool
though i i don't know i thought that was
really cool if more people discover kate
bush
because of
stranger things then i'm all about it
because kate bush is rad so
you know
strong78 yeah you know we've been like
listening to kate bush a long time i've
loved that song like forever so i
thought it was like really cool that
everybody's like into it now say sly did
you see um dolomite is my name
that's that new eddie murphy movie about
[ __ ] i mean newish yeah it came out a
couple years i mean that movie is so
[ __ ] good it's like three years so
good man it's just so [ __ ] good it's
so good it's so entertaining when that
movie when when eddie came back with
that movie he just for me just [ __ ]
blew it out of the [ __ ] park i was
like oh yeah
and it just it topped a lot of his old
stuff
and i was just going like man [ __ ] so
good to have him back and yeah you know
[ __ ] mango's
saying that well you know coming to
america too wasn't quite as good as it
should have been
it's it was because of the rating
dolomite is my name
that was was like the best i mean that
was that yes that was way better yes
indeed i mean dolan manny's my name was
like so
oh i was [ __ ] busting up to the whole
thing it was just a good story so good
and it was well and it had like a great
to be honest i know this is a weird
comparison maybe it's not a weird
comparison
dolomite is my name was almost kind of
like the
the black exploitation version
quote-unquote of ed wood
it was like weirdly like [ __ ]
inspirational yeah because like here are
these people that have no money making
it yes they have no idea and they're
we're just gonna make a movie and it's
just kind of like
their enthusiasm it's just like it's
that's [ __ ] great yeah i loved it i
love that jenny gave it to me on blu-ray
as a gift yeah dude
we got to watch that again
is my name [ __ ] great movie and sly
saying he saw he saw blacula scared him
as a kid you got the the sequel is even
better scream black honestly likes i
mean blacula is fantastic yeah
scream blacula scream
is a little bit better yeah i like that
because well i like it because it was
better i also i like it because of the
voodoo angle yeah the writing i mean i
like all that old school voodoo
no blackline screen black of the scream
actually was the main that was the main
inspiration for anne wright's vampire
chronicles when she came out with
[ __ ] you know the stop and interview
the vampire
you'd be shocked at how many films new
orleans vampires yeah that blacula and
scream blacky the scream influence yeah
they were when they said when they came
out
vampire movies hadn't been made good
ones really hadn't been made in a long
time at least not in the united states
you did have some hammer stuff that was
pretty good but in the united states
there hadn't been a good vampire moving
well
uh black screen black of the screen were
the highest budget
best
quality vampire moves that had been made
in a long time
at the time that they came out and anne
rice loved them and they had a lot of
good stuff especially in the second one
because if
the movie was more about well
what is life like for you when you're
when you're a vampire can you go out can
you go to a club no you can't
that's no that answers that there's a
couple different edits of [ __ ] screen
back in the screen and one edit that i
saw was more complete than the one that
they did that i rented on what you call
on on youtube
and when i bought the blu-ray it didn't
have the [ __ ] scene in it
where it was basically kind of like a
[ __ ]
scene about slavery
and rice talked about it in her books
the vampires enslaved people
uh mama waldy
bites
a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] voodoo priest
and turns him into a vampire but not
because he likes him he did that because
he wanted that dude's house
and then after he turned he's like oh
man this is badass and he tries to look
at himself in the mirror and he can't
see anything he's like how the [ __ ] am i
gonna
check how i look if i can't even see
myself in the mirror you know [ __ ]
i'm trying to go out he says you're not
going anywhere
he says no we talking about like you're
my [ __ ] this this
we need to go out to the club and he's
like oh
so you're going to go out and you're
going to run around with people out in
public
and you're going to bring them back here
and he's like yeah and he goes and then
they find out what we are and then they
kill us in our sleep and he's like uh he
goes you will do nothing you will stay
right here.
and he goes so i'm just going to listen
to you like i'm your slave and he goes
you are my slave
i made you
and [ __ ] they cut that out of the
[ __ ]
version that i have
and he goes i'm a slave
and [ __ ] he goes yes
[ __ ] mama waldy was
he's black but he's making people as
slaves
now well later on i got [ __ ] over by
yeah and later on he gets raped because
there's also you have you could be a
slave but there was a slave revolt and
there was later on that that particular
guy was talking about
made all the other slave vampires rise
up against mamawali they [ __ ] they
killed him i don't remember exactly how
they did it
but uh mama waldy was a [ __ ] cool
vampire
and
i wish they'd bring that character back
but really
that was a long time ago the only thing
that could ha eddie murphy could bring
back [ __ ] the vampire from vampire in
brooklyn and maybe redo that and it
would kind of be like blackup well the
thing that made blacula work
and scream blacula's green
was that
yeah it's like had some it it was made
in the 70s and it was like kind of
cheesy and stuff like that but fashion i
mean the role of blacula he took that
very seriously
and he had this gravitas yeah
and that really [ __ ] worked yeah it
really worked well he was a great actor
oh yeah
he was in star wars he was in a star
trek remember he was able to do the
[ __ ] invented the m5 computer that's
right yeah m5 yes
yeah
but uh i think that's what i loved about
that was that it was it took itself very
seriously and it and it worked when you
hear the title blacula you think it
might be some kind of joke no
well and i'm gonna say too that they did
do blaxploitation versions of like
because they did like blackenstein
pakistan the blackout sucked terrible
terrible which is terrible terrible but
blacula yeah
despite the title was actually quite
awesome yeah and actually like scream
black it looks good it's awesome now the
reason for the free for y'all they
haven't seen the movie the reason why it
was called blacula is because he in in
the opening in the first movie in the
opening scenes
he's an african lord
who's at dinner
with some dude from europe who's this
rich [ __ ]
and they're having a talk and [ __ ]
mama waldy is trying to
talking about how the development of
african of the african continent and
that that slavery was a scourge that
needed to be wiped out in africa they
were sound to
and uh the white dude
is like oh no that's not going anywhere
type of deal he tries to buy mama
waldy's wife
well it turns out he seems like a party
fowl yeah
turns out that this white dude is
dracula
and [ __ ] he attacks him
and goes through this big rigmarole he
[ __ ]
bites mamavaldi and turns him into a
vampire seals him into a [ __ ] coffin
and locks him and his wife into the
crypt and he says why you in here when
you will rise again and you will [ __ ]
you will rise again as a vampire and
and spend eternity listening to the
[ __ ] screams of your dying wife
sealed in this [ __ ] cat in this
[ __ ]
a crypt and he goes and i will give you
my name but i will call you
blacula man [ __ ] so dracula named him
blacula so that was like the white man
yeah yeah that was mama waldy his real
name was mama yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's where that's where the title
came from it was a [ __ ] wild story
man and uh the movies were good because
uh
they were black product black people
made them
and uh
i think the financing might have been at
least partially black people buying ass
behind
financed them and the [ __ ] fashion
was really good
uh they were [ __ ] showing off some
real high fashion
the hair and the [ __ ] costume it
loves a lot of outfits and it was
kind of like
70s bell bottoms and [ __ ] low hip
huggers but there was something kind of
gothic about it
you know how i found those
those movies is hanging out in new
orleans
got at a goth club called the crystal
i was talking this in those days the old
black dude he was [ __ ] regular there
her name was larry
larry was a retired new orleans pimp
and he was telling me
he loved the goth scene he goes but even
though he wasn't gothic and he was just
like man it reminds me of [ __ ]
something from blacula and he was
talking he'd tell me about black and he
told me to he recommended him to me i
was like oh come on and he's like oh no
they're good movies and when i saw him
they were [ __ ] great
and what happened to larry later on is
that
larry got arrested for bank robbery
yeah well that was his retirement plan
that was that was his retirement plan i
respect he couldn't control these hoes
anymore they're [ __ ] the younger
bucks [ __ ] took all this [ __ ] he had
nothing in life and he that he's so he
he went for broke and uh they arrested
me [ __ ] robbed the bank with a
banknote and uh gave him time this last
time i saw
but uh don't think i'm larry
o'leary yeah and larry was old school
new orleans pimp from the late 60s early
70s he was like my dad's age
that's that's how that's how i found
those movies
living in new orleans that's hilarious
and they're about new orleans yeah they
are so you know
and that his larry's
view of the [ __ ]
90s goth scene was that it reminded me
of blacula
i say that i could say that
he thought it was very cool
john gore says ganja and hess with the
uh night olympic dead guy is a pretty
interesting black vampire movie i didn't
want to watch that i think they added it
to shutter a while back and i haven't
watched it yet but yeah that's one that
like comes up a lot when you're talking
about like
that kind of we watched the we watched
the other one
what was that one called
[ __ ] i can't remember now but yeah
ganjan hess is another one that i've
been wanting to watch but we have
watching it
uh anyone seen the ss experiment from
1976
i haven't seen that one although what
there was like a whole [ __ ]
range of films that were like
she-wolf of the xss there was like there
was nazi flotation yeah there was a
whole there was none exploitation
blaxploitation
white exploitation
there was everything exploitation yeah
and there was nazi pollutation there was
a lot of nazi movies in the 70s
and a lot of them had to do with like
like ilsa she wolf of the ss she had
kind of like this weird kind of [ __ ]
where is like oh we have like this nazi
guard at this thing and she's like super
into like [ __ ]
creepy [ __ ] and she's doing all this
like weird [ __ ] to all the prisoners
yeah and that was like a whole sub genre
i've seen a few of those but i haven't
seen that one
but yeah
in case you guys didn't know oh look at
all the look at all the yeah that's it
no one got rid of it but it's okay they
went away
bought naked alert
i'm behind where was i i don't know iron
sky too we haven't seen i keep
i don't know i keep like putting i feel
like you should probably see iron sky
because i feel like you would probably
yeah everybody's talking about that
because i like nazis at the center of
the earth yeah so i feel like you'd
probably like iron guys iron sky and
like a man they made a a a sequel as
well you could probably be into that
you'd probably be into that
yeah um
sly is talking about that guy was a
stage actor from the 50s yeah his name
was uh william marshall i believe what
his name was yes he would do kind of
like shakespearean style
acting
[ __ ] slide is going to time you
killing me i don't know what
i don't know i don't know what i was
saying back then man i'm going back into
the comments
kind of ozone says never seen nazis at
the center oh nazi's the center oh it's
fun
nazis at the center of the earth was the
[ __ ]
um
what's the name of that company uh
was it the one that does all the like
knock-offs does all the dogs i think it
is uh asylum asylum asylum
which i i think it's asylum it's rock
bottom rock bottom
well their whole thing i mean they make
money they make money they're like hey a
big movie comes out we're going to make
like a rip-off of that the thing is and
call it almost the same thing the thing
is about nazis at the center of the
earth is that that movie is legitimate
all right it's an individual it's a it's
a unique creation
that conforms perfectly
to early german science fiction
that that um that the nazis liked uh
which is their the main
one of the main books that germans liked
in the in in the early 1900s was
something called
vril the coming power
and uh it was about an underground
species
of
humans
uh that lived inside of a hollow earth
that had
harnessed a certain energy called vril
real energy could run all these machines
and it could it was kind of like the
force but it was also kind of like a
laser beams too
uh
and
nazis at the center of the earth
is a [ __ ] good sci-fi horror movie
that every
aspect of the movie
conforms to german science fiction
that the national socialists would have
known about
and
stuff that was added on top of it in the
ensuing years in other words like
hitler's head being preserved
hitler
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh all kinds of just
nazis making zombies uh
nazis uh in the center of the earth in a
hollow earth coming out in
in in ufos powered by vril to destroy
the modern world so they could take over
and they're also the undead at the same
time i mean sure yeah it's just wild as
[ __ ] wild as [ __ ] why not just wild as
[ __ ] and
the first time i saw it
because i know their lore and the
legends and all the paranormal [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you find you know about the
nazi bell and all this weird stuff
and i just [ __ ] loved it and busted
up through the whole [ __ ] movie
because every crazy thing they show you
is like oh yeah yeah of course i know
exactly what they're talking about yeah
it's some kind of a [ __ ] legend yeah
they didn't just pull that out they're
at yeah yeah that was well written yeah
it was it was as well somebody knew a
lot about nazi lore of that yeah that
made that move it was as good as
velocipaster even though it was very
different velocipaster was
i kind of feel like a kung fu
philosopher yeah and we've said this
before i kind of feel like velocipaster
is like the platonic ideal yeah
so bad it's good movie yeah velocipaster
knew that it was terrible and ran with
it and and and yeah
and it became turns around and becoming
awesome
and yes the thing about it is that even
though it knows it's bad and it's trying
to be a bad movie it doesn't it still
comes across as very earnest it's a good
movie which in fact like makes it
funnier yeah because it doesn't come
across as like flip or meta or anything
it's thought out very well yeah they so
they're really like committed
to the premise that they had right the
fact that it seemed genuine
made it like way funnier right because
you have a lot of movies that are like
trying to be bad on purpose
and those are not as funny no because
you get this sense of like oh i'm like
above this material i'm just like i'm
trying to be funny i'm perfect like
ghost shark and [ __ ] yeah it's like
cerses yeah it's like to me that's like
that's not funny velocipaster was funny
because they
knew that it was a bad movie but they
were somehow able to convey
that it was still like a genuine so it
still came across as they were trying to
make a good movie and it went terribly
awry
kinda i guess but they
but they but you still knew that they
knew that they were making a bad movie
but it didn't like you interfere with
yourself back around sure it comes back
around as it's a good movie because a
movie is supposed to entertain you and
that [ __ ] was entertaining as a
[ __ ] and what makes it
entertaining was the writing and the way
[ __ ] was shot
um that everything about this
philosopher is a genius movie everything
about that genius every single thing
like made me laugh
it was made with no money
but what could not what you can never
replace is writing
and edit
and just the
and the way things were shot in the
movie
you just can't stop watching it and you
understand everything that happens and
is pulling you in
it's not throwing you out it's pulling
you in deeper
it's kind of like
a movie
a kung fu movie about dinosaurs and
ninjas
as if it's happening on a [ __ ]
video screen in the ninth
and it or it's also a video a 1982 video
game it's just
everything that was ridiculous
about the 80s
is all happening
but it makes sense and it's it and the
movie also had its own lore
you know it it kept itself confined
to a narrative it didn't break its own
narrative it didn't it was
a cohesive movie that could only be done
with
through an overarching concept and good
writing
so no
the masterpiece of all
cheap movies like so bad it's good
movies is velocipaster
i kind of feel like yeah yeah that's
like the pluton i'll laugh through the
whole [ __ ] thing that was like which
was super and you're supposed to
it did its job well like i said we would
have loved that movie in high school we
would i mean we loved it we've talked
about this a lot because like i said i
mean you guys know i'm a huge msc fan so
i've seen like a lot of
bad movies that came out in the
40s 50s 60s
the thing that makes those movies funny
is that they thought that they were
making a good
movie yeah
and it went drastically awry at some
point
like ed wood
i feel like he probably thought
he thought that he was making good
movies yeah um but he just didn't really
have any concept of like what made a
good movie and that's what made it
hilarious was that juxtaposition between
what he thought was a good movie and
what everyone else in the world thought
was a good movie so that's what makes it
funny but the thing about it was that
when you had this whole like self-aware
thing that kind of came out in the 90s
like with sharknado and all that kind of
stuff you kind of got people that were
making movies it's like oh well we know
there's a big audience for like so bad
it's good movies so we're gonna do that
on purpose
and
if you're gonna do it on purpose
it doesn't really work out the same
uh 99 of the time it doesn't work out at
all like a lot of the times you're
trying to make a bad movie and you're
like look how funny we're being and it's
just like it doesn't work for me because
it's like you're trying too hard yeah um
so i feel like that's where velocipaster
and that's what i'm saying this like
that's why it's like a really hard
balance to strike because
you have to like strike a balance
between
we want this to seem like it's
genuine
like we're not trying to be too cynical
uh you know and we're also not trying to
be like i don't know we're trying to
like not to be overt about anything and
i feel like they they got that balance
exactly
right
in that movie now there's another movie
that also they got everything [ __ ]
right and i [ __ ] love it i want to
get it on blu-ray
it's a post-apocalyptic low-budget
superhero movie
called turbo kid
yeah turbo cut is great turbo kid was
about perfect had michael ironside in it
playing the [ __ ] bad guys and it had
a lot of 80s and 90s sci-fi tropes in it
that you'll recognize when you see it i
think it might have been a french movie
huh it's in english but i think it might
the french might have had something to
do with it i don't know who's french or
french canadian french canadian maybe i
can't remember real good or hated a
while back good great tone good editing
it's kind of like going back in time
when movies were [ __ ] fun to watch
it's just called turbo kid and it's a
like a
a post-apocalyptic superhero movie like
imagine if you're in the world's kind of
like fallout the video game fallout and
mad max together
and you have the ability to become a
superhero about a young boy young guy
who becomes a superhero which is [ __ ]
when you think about it it's [ __ ]
crazy but it makes sense when you see
the movie
and uh there's androids in it and robots
and there's androids and cyborgs in it
and
mad max style [ __ ]
gangs and there isn't any cars they just
use bmx bicycles which that makes a lot
of sense because you don't need fuel
yeah because i mean if it's apocalypse i
would get a bicycle that's probably i'd
get a bicycle and a ninja sword yeah bmx
this is the first two things yeah that i
would get yeah but it was that's a good
movie
turbo kid
kind of otzon says this is a fun trivia
name the top five
movie directors of all time in your
opinion
oh [ __ ]
kubrick kubrick
um
well for me kubrick
david lynch yeah
uh
john carpenter yeah
um coppola yeah
lucas is a good idea man but i don't
really think he's a really good director
i like [ __ ] um the dude who did
[ __ ] um
raiders the lost ark and all that field
spielberg yeah yeah
yeah that's a yeah yeah all right
it was the top five
i mean
although all those guys did very
different kind of movies
and um
carpenter was hit or miss some of the
carpenter movies i don't believe he
directed i think somebody else directed
him that's what i'm saying like
carpenter i'm mostly not for like well
yeah like i'm mostly saying that for his
early [ __ ] but to be honest
if he had just done halloween and the
thing
and escaped from new york and escaped
from new york that would be sufficient
and halloween three oh dario argento
yeah that's my fifth one sorry attention
he did a halloween three didn't he yeah
yeah i think carpenter directly he might
have produced it i don't think he
directed it but please correct me if i'm
wrong people don't like it people didn't
like three when it came out but what's
your favorite halloween movie it's three
well like i said season of the witch
it's different now because
at the time but it give everyone was
pissed off because like oh it doesn't
have michael myers in it yeah but now no
one's expecting that so
i kind of feel like it's gotten like a
lot of reassessment so to me it'd be
like kubrick carpenter
uh what did i say
coppola yeah
uh
dario i'm i'm super into dario gento
even though his later [ __ ] was crap but
like okay and spielberg
yeah i mean how long we've been home
uh three hours okay it's time for us to
go because i gotta [ __ ] uh do the
cakes and get something to eat and spend
oh you gotta mix like some pocky cakes
yeah and i can make something to eat too
what are you gonna make i don't know
we'll see what's down there
it's got a sandwich
limousine says hitchcock yeah that too
yeah that too i mean there's so many
it's like i'd i'd have to do top 10.
mario baba
now that you're like bringing it up i'm
thinking of like lots of stuff but yeah
billy wilder some people said sam pekka
paw yeah tarantino yeah okay cecil beat
a mill
i mean there's too many there's too many
to like narrow it down
i'm just saying all right so we've been
on for like three hours
we're starving yeah we're gonna go get
something to eat
so hopefully you guys have a good
beginning of your weekend we will be
back on sunday evening
talking about
whatever movie we end up watching
tonight or tomorrow night i don't really
know what that'll be about
or we might do another sidetrack show
we'll see how it goes
you all right yeah okay why are you
laughing
[Laughter]
laughing get you drunk trying to close
the show out
why are you judging okay i gotta go
you're drunk too i gotta go i gotta go
i'm gonna judge me for me to drop get it
get some blue bread yeah go get some
food seriously all right so you guys
have a good weekend we will see you guys
on
sunday afternoon hopefully you guys will
drop by and join us
thank you for dropping by this evening
we will see you guys
on sunday
bye